anh alo lên chưa
anh Alo chờ tất cả bạn
Ừ
bắt đầu từ buổi hôm nay chắc là các bạn
sẽ nghe được mình nói có vẻ mượt hơn tốt
hơn bởi vì mình vừa mới đầu tư con tai
nghe cũng bằng tiền con Mic bà cụ
gì để mà nghe thực sự là mình đăng mình
đang nói như thế nào ấy
a comic ngày sẽ cắm hàng của à còn tai
nghe sẽ cắt ra một mic để biết được
thế nên sẽ Sau vụ này chắc là chất lượng
mọi thứ mình sẽ trình lại được về âm
lượng cũng như là tốc độ giọng nói có
thứ thứ
thì các bạn thấy màn hình chơi nhỉ Đang
khiến màn hình rồi đúng không ạ
từ hôm nay chắc là sẽ là buổi cuối để
HTML
ạ sau đó tuần sau chúng ta sẽ học sáng
CS CS thì ra là cũng chỉ có 23 buồn gì
đó sau đó chúng ta sẽ nhạy sáng ra
Switch Thật ra thì các bạn sẽ nó vẫn là
kiểu thỉnh thoảng các bạn vẫn sẽ phải tự
ôn tập hoa quả mình sẽ xảy ra bài tập để
để các bạn ạ ôn đi
khi bị vọng âm á
em có bị vọng
à à
à à Thực tế là không phải là vì sau sẽ
ít buổi mà
à Không phải cứ cứ thế này cho đến về
sau là chỉ ít bụi như thế mà là con em
được a mình chỉ dậy ở mức tương đối rồi
để cho các bạn cậu
các bạn chỉ nói chung các bạn chỉ cần
biết qua thôi đương nhiên là về sau sẽ
áp dụng nhiều nên là mình đang dạy những
cái một đẹp về sau áp dụng
để nhưng mà nghĩa về sau mình sẽ không
nhắc lại cái khái niệm kiến thức của cái
đấy nữa chứ không có nghĩa là là ít buổi
là vì sau pp cũng chỉ có ba bốn buổi
à mà thực sự thì cái khác trên mật độ
chuyên sâu nặng chẳng có cái gì nữa hình
trên Sau đó các bạn Vì sao gọi sẽ đi học
Giống như mình mình làm web từ 52 cho
đến bây giờ hả toàn bộ những kiến thức
mình đang mình đang dạy các bạn cũng mà
đầy đủ tất cả kiến thức mình đã biết đấy
thì các bạn sẽ thấy à Cậu nó không cần
phải biết nhiều có những cái các bạn chỉ
cần biết kiểu đủ để mà các bạn dùng
thường xuyên thì thôi các bạn chuyên về
bên bác em à Đó Ngoại Ô
anh ở đây hôm trước thì ra còn nhiều bạn
hỏi câu kia có hỏi gần đây thì mình thấy
càng ít hơn nhưng mà công nhận là có hỏi
nó vẫn có cái độ chất lượng gì đó
chi tiết thì mình
cho
mình trước khi mình chia sẻ những cái
trả lời những câu hỏi kia câu hỏi để
mang thì kiến thức nữa mình chắc mình sẽ
không trả lời vội mà mình sẽ thử lại tâm
sự một tí không ạ ạ
anh em học VNEN trước rồi mới sang bác
em Ừ thì tất cả mọi người ở đây đang Thế
mày không ạ thì đều đang học mang em
trước rồi nhưng sáng bye em mà
anh nói chung là ATM này mình sẽ có bốn
buổi tâm tâm đấy nữa hai tuần không ạ
xong rồi sẽ thì cũng tầm ba bốn buổi
thôi xong rồi ra quyết thì chắc là nhiều
hơn vì nó ngôn ngữ lập trình mình đâu
mình dạy các bạn ra Swift thì mình sẽ
phải dạy lại các bạn thế nào là ngôn ngữ
lập trình nữa nên có thể nó khô khan hơn
một tí bởi vì có nhiều Bạn thì nhiều bạn
đến thời hiện tại rồi
bạn đấy học qua cái khóa học của thầy
thầy Tuấn away điện hạ thì biết qua thế
nào ngôn ngữ lập trình rồi nhưng mà mình
vẫn phải dạy lại để cho thực sự những
bạn nào mới chưa biết hoặc là biết đâu
Bạn đang học à Kiểu học kiểu có thể là
bị hỏng Đến Ước gì gì đó đóng ngoặc
thì mình sẽ dạy gian quý vị Chắc là phải
mất nhiều thời gian hơn
Ừ nếu mà mục tiêu của mình chạy ra quyết
không phải để mà áp dụng hoàn toàn do
Spear mà học ra Switch để
mình hiểu qua giao tiếp cả gì ra Kích có
tác dụng gì mình sẽ áp dụng dao Speed để
mà làm virus và đến chính là valid from
cái thứ mà hôm nay mình sẽ học và hôm
nay mình sẽ nói cụ thể và đấy là cái gì
Đồng hoặc
sau đó tiếp thì mình sẽ ngời sáng p.song
ngọn thì TP thì mình thử cao chỉ cần
lướt nhanh qua thôi lên ngang qua vì
mình biết ra Switch ngôn ngữ lập trình
dã ngoại thì TP đi mình sẽ chỉ cần lướt
qua nhanh theo kiểu lạ với pp thì cú
pháp nó thay đổi như nào thì trả chị chỉ
có 23 buồn ạ sau đó thì không phải là
thế kết thúc khóa học mà sau đó thì như
mình đã nói thì mình đang cân nhắc là sẽ
cho các bạn chia theo nhóm mỗi nhóm 2
bạn mình sẽ cho ta tạo một cái trang gì
đó để mà các bạn random để mà kiểu Chọn
ngẫu nhiên hai bạn bất kỳ để hai bạn ơi
sẽ chung một nhóm sau đó thì các bạn sẽ
chọn một trong những đề tài Hoặc ra các
bạn thể tự nghĩ về tài tùy chọn một
trong những đề tài Mình gợi ý để mà sau
đó mình sẽ dạy các bạn về hạ hai cái đề
tài mà thường là phổ biến nhưng mình nói
đó là trang web bán hàng hoặc cả trong
cái tin tức trả tin tức trước khi gửi
tính thức dễ hơn thì mình sẽ dạy qua các
bạn để mà làm một cái trang web từ đầu
đến cuối
thì nó sẽ phải cần như thế nào
Ừ để các bạn hình dung được đóng ngoặc
sau đó thì các bạn mà
áp dụng kiến thức đã học để mà làm hoặc
cứ mỗi một buổi mình sẽ chữa từng từng
cái từng cái những tính năng chính những
tính năng quan trọng của trang web đấy
Thực ra là gần như là các các bạn chỉ
cần ôm toàn bộ những cái cốt của mình
hôm hôm đầy chữa về đã hình đã hình
thành xong cái trang web rồi
các bạn chỉ cần thêm những cái giao diện
hoa cả thêm những tính năng con nữa là
xong thì
ạ sau đó đi mình Mình sợ nhỉ sau đó thì
mình sẽ nhảy sang trang web bán hàng bán
hàng nên phức tạp hơn một tí ở đó sau
cái bán hàng thì chắc à mình nghĩ là
mình sẽ để cho các bạn dư thời gian ra
sự dư thời gian ra để các bạn tự học tự
làm một cái một cái phần
nói chung À thì ra lúc mà mình đang dậy
là các bạn cũng sẽ phải tự làm rồi để
làm cái trang web kia đó ngon nó chua
một cái đâu bán đấy thì nó sẽ phải tầm
hai tháng 2 3 tháng để các bạn
vì thế các bạn làm xong được tương đối
hoàn thiện rồi
mình sẽ cân nhắc thời vụ là các bạn kia
đang gợi ý có thể qua dung thì phải mình
sẽ bảo vệ quá Dung nhé mình sẽ cho các
bạn bảo vệ quá Run cho các thầy cô và
nhận xét
chị đánh giá thợ trẻ em Mình có thể kêu
một bên tuyển dụng ở đó về
bộ phim ma kiểu đấy xem các bạn có
chuyện vọng hay không để để đi được tập
bên này luôn đúng ạ
Ừ nhưng mà nói chung là cứ kết thúc cái
khóa cơ bản này thì thì mục tiêu của
mình sẽ là ai cũng biết cái website từ
đầu đến cuối làm như thế nào và nó hoạt
động được như thế nào Vân Vân Vân đóng
ngoặc đấy Sau đó thì các bạn sẽ cân nhắc
xin việc là các bạn muốn tiếp tục theo
ngành Công nghệ thông tin nữa không
ờ ờ theo ngành bên ít nhất ở bên lập
trình web này hay không là sử bạn thích
lập trình cho bạn Ghét Web bạn ạ con nếu
là bạn có tư duy từng giống mình nhá đó
là mình thích lập trình Nhưng mà mình
ghét ta Làm kiểu mấy website bán hàng nó
rất xinh Tin tức thực ra là như mình đã
từng nó thì lúc mà mình về xu tiên công
ty mình mới phát hiện ra là mình thể áp
dụng các kiến thức này để mà làm bí thư
khác ví dụ như là
Ý mình là làm hạn cung về Facebook chẳng
hạn hay cắt sữa xứ
cho nên là hoàn toàn các bạn có thể là
làm thêm rất nhiều cái nữa chứ không
phải về mỗi về mỗi mấy cái của mình đang
dậy đúng không ạ
khi đặt câu hỏi thì các bạn cứ hỏi ở
chính cái Các bạn cứ bình luận nữa rồi
mình sẽ xem lại tất cả các bình luận các
bạn để ghi lại những câu hỏi
à à
ở đầu tiên thì
ạ bây giờ đến thật còn Tam phút để tâm
sự đúng à mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ trả lời nhanh à Thế thì
không này sẽ có lạ
anh cũng
anh chia sẻ một chút về công việc của
mình đi
a tool về Facebook thì trường là ngôn
ngữ gì mình thời gian mình trả lời con
này rất nhiều rồi nhưng mà mình sẽ trả
lời lại lần cuối trên doubt mình nhé đó
là ngôn ngữ lập trình nào nó cũng như
nhau thế nên là các bạn áp dụng ngôn ngữ
lập trình nào để mà làm bất kỳ cái gì
cũng được kể cả tu này thứ hai bất kỳ
tuổi mày cái gì tự nhiên là mỗi cái ngôn
ngữ lập trình nào có một thế mạnh riêng
của nó dù ở dạng như p thì chuyên đề web
nó là kẻ của nó sẽ chạy được trên web
còn là kiểu dạng là xui hay xây xác Java
thì nó sẽ là về ứng dụng nghĩa là ứng
dụng trên máy tính hoặc là ứng dụng trên
điện thoại đời vân vân Thì nghĩa là mỗi
ngôn ngữ lập trình nó sẽ hiểu chạy được
trên main tả khác nhau nhưng mà nó đều
có công dụng là để làm được rất nhiều
cái mà các bạn muốn nó tự động a tool
Facebook bản Chắc là nó là thay vì các
bạn thủ công ngồi làm thì máy tính nó
làm hộ các bạn Điền hình gần đây nhất
nhé gần đây nhất mình có tự nhiên có một
bạn nào đó Đào bày ở trên lưu tim công
ty lên phải bảo là
các bạn từng hỏi và mình đã từng trả lời
cái câu đấy từ hai năm trước rồi sao tự
nhiên có bạn nào hôm trước mới đào lên
mình mới đọc lại thì mình cảm thấy hồi
đấy là mình đã ngu nghiên cứu rất nhiều
và mình chia sẻ rất nhiều hai năm trước
Và nếu mà ông nào ở trong nhóm như tín
với thì tầm 2 năm trước thì thấy gần như
là cứ 1 tháng mà mình sẽ đang ngồi tung
Facebook một lần thì tu lần đấy thì là
có bạn bà là bạn ấy muốn xóa toàn bộ
những cái bạn bè à Sao toàn bộ những
thành viên không tương tác cho ạ thì bản
chất cái việc và xóa toàn bộ thành viên
không tương tác ở trong nhóm ấy hoặc là
ít nhất ở trong khoảng tầm 30 ngày đổi
lại khi thực chất thì nó là các bạn sẽ
phải lấy tất cả số lượng những số những
số thành viên đã tương tác cho 30 ngày
đúng không ạ
ạ sau đó đi thì các bạn à Lấy tổng tổng
số thành viên nhóm sau đó - lấy số thành
viên đã tương tác trong 30 ngày thì ra
được những người không tương tác trong
30 ngày đấy Đúng rồi các bạn Xóa hết đi
Thôi thì đương nhiên là để mà làm điều
này thủ công thì các bạn ngồi không biết
nhập Excel thì bao giờ ngoan đấy thì hãy
để máy tính là lừa đấy đúng không Máy
tính sẽ ngồi lấy hết ta hậu trợ các bạn
xong rồi được trừ cho nhau cho nó ra
ngoài
hai nhóm chính nhóm yootheme committee
đây chắc là có khi bạn này không chụp
nhầm đấy
Ờ Ờ bạn kia có hỏi đó là hết khóa swil
thì có mình còn nên mình có nên gộp cái
cái lớp lập trình web mày vào cái thứ
năm mới không ra mình đang cân nhắc cái
đấy mình mình đang cân nhắc rồi đấy khá
nhiều về thực sự đi 2 buổi 1 tuần thì ra
lại thoải mái cho cốc các bạn là đang
theo ở đây vì các bạn có thể đang bận
rộn rất nhiều cái có ông vừa bảo là em
phải ngồi xem chung kết thế giới đang cả
xem anh xong
thì cái này cân nhắc nhưng mà Đúng là để
mà học Thành Công đúng không học để mà
thành tài cả đời mà rèn thì đúng là
không phải ba buổi một tuần đâu ngồi đấy
là hồi Mình làm từ đồ án này là ngày nào
lên trường ngồi làm xong rồi đêm cũng
ngồi làm đúng không Thì không có chuyện
một kiểu hai buổi Online 1 tuần mà mỗi
bữa ăn ở gần tiếng là đủ sẽ sáng là
không rồi Ông Không Thể Lương nghìn đô
với cái kiểu học hơi hợp như thế được
mấy người chắc chắn không ạ Nhưng mà
chắc à mình sẽ cân nhắc việc là mình sẽ
phải hoàn thành 3 buổi
ừ ừ
a Nhớ bé mình đang cân nhắc để xem các
bạn thế nào đã tự nhiên mình mình tăng
lên với cùng chẳng ai xem rồi thì nhớ
mình mình tự kỷ buồn đúng không ạ
cho tôi Tôi cần người xem thật nhé Tôi
không cần mấy ông ngồi hack để xem tôi
hay là ngồi cả máy treo rồi bỏ đi chơi
nhé bởi vì đây không Chúng ta không cần
những điều đấy đây ạ
à à
ờ ờ
em không bắt đầu dậy thì tôi vẫn sẽ cố 8
giờ bắt đầu dậy thì cho các bạn chuẩn
giờ
ừ ừ
có mấy câu hỏi kia của mấy ông cho tôi
xin phép trả lời ở đây sẽ tiện nhé mình
trả lời luôn về cậu anh chia sẻ thêm về
công việc của anh đi đúng không ạ thì
công việc của mình các bạn sẽ nghĩ là
mình đang làm lập trình web thì mình sẽ
làm gì công ty hạn nó như thế Tại mình
làm công ty là công ty về thương mại
điện từ mình sẽ không tiện khoe tên ở
đây cho dù có thể sẽ tốt một tí đó cho
công ty mình xin kẹo được quảng cáo thời
gian mình không thích tính mình không
thích quảng cáo dành cho là mình sẽ
không chia sai dưới đây
thì ạ công ty mình về Thương Mại Đầu Tư
và làm chủ yếu bên nước ngoài thôi
Ừ thì mình cũng ta là nếu thế thì các
bạn sẽ nghĩ học tiếng Anh mình phải giỏi
lắm nhưng thật ra anh chỉ cần biết đủ
đại học tài liệu và chọn May mà mình có
thức có một tí tiếng Anh thỉnh thoảng
mình cũng sẽ họp với họ thì mình cũng
hiểu na ná nhưng mà mình nói thì vẫn là
kém Bởi vì em mình không điện nhiều cái
nói mình kiểu Xem phim nhiều nhưng thấy
nó biết em
à à và chủ và cái quan trọng nhất là
mình làm gì không ạ thì mình làm cả
fullstack với công ty áp thì thường
người ta thường nhân lực theo kiểu là
không không thể làm ạ những kiểu ông Chị
Chuyên một mạng được ông càng Brazil anh
làm tốt thế thành ra là lại rất trọng
dụng những cái con người
Kiểu gì cũng kiểu gì cũng có thể nhảy
giống như mình mình sẽ ra mình không hả
chuyện là giao diện nhưng mình biết về
gia Suite và như mình đã nói thì các bạn
hoàn toàn thể ôm một cái giao diện nào
đó tem bếp Lúc mà tôi đi nó mà tôi dậy
rồi Công về sau tôi sẽ dậy ông ăn cắp
giao diện đâu đó với mà không ạ thì thì
hoàn toàn là mấy cái kiểu Wechat hay có
thứ template có sẵn rồi Mình chỉ copy về
mà dùng sau đó thì mình đương nhiên phải
cốt đoạn ra clip riêng sợ đó thì mình
dùng pp thôi Nó ngoan Để mình cái nồi
lên các thứ thì làm À thì ra ở làm của
tôi nó chẳng chuyên Chẳng cần biết tí gì
thuật toán nhưng mà Đúng là làm ở cái
công ty của mình nó đang có tầm khá là
to thì ra kiểu dữ liệu lớn nên là đúng à
sẽ phải biết thêm sâu một tí về AK Wow
nếu mà ông không biết tối ưu điển hình
gần đây nhất nhé hồi trước tôi không
không để vụ đầy lắm thì thành ra kiểu
câu câu chuy vật của mình rất là đơn
giản hay ra là gần đây bị
sập vì vậy sắp mười mấy phút thì phải à
à Chỉ vì là kiểu câu truy vấn một câu
truy vấn trong cái bảng hơn mấy chục
triệu bản ghi lại ra chết nên là lúc đấy
phải tìm các để mã cậu tối như câu đấy
Nói chung nào kia là sao đáp thì các bạn
sẽ phải
cũng bị Hơi bị có tải một tí quá tải
thiếu nhân lực cũng như kiểu
có lương thì chắc chắn là startup thường
là lương nó sẽ khởi điểm mà không cao
như stop có cái lợi là nếu mà bạn báo
sớm thì vì sau
những người vào sau bạn thì dưới quyền
của bạn mà mẹ Hay mẹ nó đi
ờ ờ
mà bị đền không
không cần để thực ra chẳng đền ai đây cả
bởi vì cái này không phải lỗi do một
mình mình kêu dạng là đứa như mình làm
cái đoạn đấy hãy nhận lỗi các bạn sẽ
nghĩ lỗi của mình nhưng mà thực tế là
kéo nó bởi vì a nó sát thì nha kẹo nọ
chưa có cái gì đó khắt khe ghê gớm cả
dám mua cũng như là kéo họ vẫn đang cần
người kết hợp với yếu tố là kéo họ ở
dạng là bây giờ ai cũng ai cũng kiểu
cũng mới
Anh cũng mới biết anh cái vụ đấy
e k có một phải anh ở trong này thì cũng
rất là cậu có nhiều năm kinh nghiệm mồi
nhưng mà kiểu mình mới thấy ra cậu tròn
trách gì cả Mình nghĩ là thế nhưng mà
cái này không liên quan đến vụ là cậu
ảnh hưởng đến tiền nong lắm
kiểu không làm bị thiệt hại ghê gớm thì
ra là cậu cũng đang ổn
Ừ thôi nhà Trung Hà xanh bây giờ bắt đầu
trả lời những cái câu kia nhá
Thử ta là cái câu khái niệm về phương
word Moly và smartphone thì mình xin
phép mình sẽ trả lời sau điện
3 cách để làm tôm săn mã shopee hay
Facebook em mình trả lời trước này thì
như mình vừa nãy có nói đó là ngôn ngữ
lập trình nào cũng thể làm được một cái
tôn thì cái tool để mà sẵn mã shopee ở
Facebook bị bản chất là mình cái kiểu là
a tune Nó là kiểu dạng là các bạn hay vì
kiểu lên từng trang của sản phẩm các bạn
tìm mã rồi Các bạn xem mã thấy giảm giờ
bao nhiêu tiền với Vân thì sẽ có 1 con
boss nó sẽ tự động các bạn sẽ cốt ra con
boss đấy thì nó tự động nên tất cả các
trang đấy Họ sẽ tìm kiếm cho tên vân
tay kiểu thế đêm để mà kiểu nó sẽ Liệt
kê lại ra danh sạch những cái mã để thôi
Ừ thế nào mình nghĩ là sau cái khóa học
này các bạn đã hoàn toàn thì biết làm
được những cái đấy
a tiếp theo anh chia sẻ với bút tre đi
quốc tế là trong khóa này của mình Mình
sẽ không Không dậy với bút pháp
anh và chị các khóa sau quá về lập trình
web nâng cao thì mình sẽ chỉ hướng dẫn
các bạn về cách áp dụng bút chép lẫn cả
có thể một tí Thư viện của j aziz thực
hiện series spa thứ để mà ôm template về
cho nó đẹp chứ mình sẽ không dậy về về
cái đấy bạn sẽ phải tự tìm hiểu cái đấy
rồi là đấy giờ đơn giản
hai iPhone Là cái thẻ iPhone ở đây hôm
trước mình có Đề cập về cái vụ là kiểu
các bạn không dùng thẻ không dùng thẻ
kiểu
video nữa mà các bạn sẽ dùng thể iPhone
ví dụ cụ thể iPhone Là cái gì thật sự
mình đó có áo
sẽ các bạn này thì đây ấn vào cái em Bơ
thì nó sẽ trăm cái gọi là iPhone này bạn
chất iPhone này nó là cái nhúng nóng
nhúng một cái trang web bất kỳ hoặc một
cái gì đó về trên trang web cả các bạn
chạy theo dạng live stream hoàn toàn loa
kiểu các bạn hoàn toàn nhúng trang web
khác về đồng ngoan giống như nhúng hẳn
video của YouTube về những này chắc lại
đây đấy kiểu quay phim ý
ở tại và mình speak chữa máy cái thẻ ra
ý của bài hôm bài hôm trước được bài ôn
tập nên thực ra là mình chủ yếu mình sẽ
chữa cái câu này thôi sữa thẻ để mà bấm
để không phải mỗi để bấm để gọi đâu ạ
Mình sẽ là và cái câu này mình xin phép
là tí thì cuối buổi gì nhất mình để mình
sẽ chỉ các bạn phải câu trả lời câu cuối
anh nhá Ừ
bộ phim mẹ cái từ này cái thứ 7 từ cấm
mình đang phải lưu lại để
ưu điểm mà mình đang làm cái cái kiểu về
mạng xã hội thì ra mấy cái từ cấm thì
mình phải loại bỏ nó đi chứ không phải
mình đang chơi chưa
ở đây ừ ừ
em tắt đi đã
em giả sử ở đây đối ngoại đã sửa đây
mình có tự nhiên là một cái thẻ đúng
không ạ
thì mình sẽ có là Facebook này sau đó
thì mình sẽ có hollis đấy sẽ nhảy đến
trang Facebook đúng không sự facebook
chụp con này à
từ cái cho mình chạy thử cái này
Dù sao đây cũng bấm vào đây nó sẽ ra
trang Facebook đúng không
đề thi
ý thì cái à
Ừ cái ở đây một mình sẽ chỉ các bạn lần
lượt từng cái một nhá
Thứ nhất là
thì các bạn còn chưa biết là Facebook
với thể viết tắt từ như thế này nó nhà
Em thử nhé
Sự Thật Chết các bạn biết là nó thì bất
chấp từ như thế nào
Anh tên miền này cực đắt Đây nhé mình
nhớ tên miền facebook.com nữa 3 tỷ đô
vậy 3 tỷ phải chịu đồ cho ba triệu Độ
ê ê facebook.com lại bị khóa rồi nhưng
sao mình lại thường ai dùng cả Facebook
chấm mi thì phải
Ừ cái này thì như là Facebook rõ thì mới
được
ưu đãi
em không nhớ cái này Facebook chứng minh
được không
anh này vẫn được này đấy
thì các bạn có như bạn thì chưa biết
đường link này
nhưng đây không phải cái thứ mà mình
đang định nói mà bây giờ sử là sự nhé
mình à
em có ai đi cũng bạn nào đó vẫn chị ID
bản thân mình đi xem nhớ mình có lưu ID
và thân bị không
ở trẻ
bộ truyện quen quen
chứ
không phải không
Có ai đi bạn thân mình tại sao mình vào
được
mình đang đăng xuất Facebook ra lại tí
mình cho các bạn xem một cái phom thì à
Ừ để xem mình lấy được ID bản thân mình
không nhé Chẳng biết nó lộ ra ở đây mình
thì đi nữa không
à à
Anh
có thể làm như kiểu này kansuru em à xem
Suốt này xong rồi gõ 1000 kiểu Nga
đấy đã già đi Này
tại sao tự nhiên mình cần ID của
Facebook của mình làm để làm gì để mà
bây giờ hôm trước có bạn chia sẻ là có
một đường link kìa Facebook của tôi đây
là này để ngon xong rồi bạn ấy muốn là
kiểu bấm bấm vào đây nó sẽ nhảy sang cái
trang của bạn ấy thì có khỏe theo ID này
đúng không ạ em mình thử nhé
ở đấy đợi đi nếu mà mình ghi rõ nha Thì
chắc chắn các bạn thường mà phải đi đầy
đủ nhà rồi
à à
thế này nó xảy ra đến Facebook của mình
đúng
ở những nhưng mà cái này thì lại dễ quá
cái mà mình đang muốn nói các bạn từ Mỗi
hôm trước đó là chủ yếu Bây giờ người
dùng dùng không phải dùng máy tính đâu ạ
mà các bạn mà người dùng dùng bằng điện
thoại cơ Thế bây giờ là sự người dùng
bấm não cái link nó phải mở bằng ứng
dụng ở trên máy trên máy điện thoại của
người đấy thì nó mới gọi là hoàn thiện
đúng hoặc khi các bài toán ở đây đó là
thứ nhất là bấm vào số điện thoại nó sẽ
mở ứng dụng áp ra để gọi bấm link
Facebook nó phải Mở Facebook lên
3000 bạn kia đang nói là dụng user name
không cần ai đi cũng được đúng nhưng mà
cái dùng ai đi thì nó mới mới có thể mở
bằng ứng dụng được ấy thế em ạ Mình đang
bắt buộc phải dùng ngay đi chứ mình biết
dùng user name thì K nó vẫn nhận không ạ
ở đây đầu tiên nhá Thôi chị mày ông này
đầu tiên à để mà ra sự ví dụ lên một số
điện thoại đúng mà là sự ngay ông luôn
bấm ở đây thì ông sẽ gọi cho ai đó đúng
ạ thì mình sẽ có khái niệm là hạ kính
thể tra Google luôn đúng không telephone
a HTML Hazard đã xảy ra đấy thì nó sẽ là
thêm chữ viết tắt này như thế này sau đó
thì số điện thoại như này trở lại đó cho
hơn Bấm dù này đó sẽ bảo là kiểu nó sẽ
hiển thị ra một cái cậu như này để mà
bạn sẽ gọi Cái số đấy bằng cái gì đó Cái
này tôi thề là tượng rất ít Trang web
nào dùng khẳng định luôn bây giờ mấy ông
và một cái trang đặt hàng kiểu đặt hàng
đồ ăn gì gió Ông bấm chữ điện thoại ông
bấm vào mấy cái cơ thậm chí là nó không
cho copy Em
phải nhớ rồi thoát ra ứng dụng điện
thoại không gọi thành công bấm vào đường
link này được Tức là nó nhảy không lại
mấy cái đơn giản này tôi thể được trái
Tôi bảo là để em cốc hội đoạn đấy cho nó
như ngắm thôi cái kiểu thế này tiếp theo
là có thể gửi được mail luôn Ví dụ là sự
là mail của mình là như này sẵn
thì mình tra ở đây mình đổi là trên mail
cản ạ
chợ hoa thì nó sẽ làm em ô tô như này
đều ạ Nó sẽ thêm chữ khái niệm làm nail
tu như này Và thậm chí cái mô tô này nó
Con hoàn toàn có thể là là có thể truyền
được thêm nội dung nữa Khi mà bấm vào nó
sẽ có thể chuyển thêm ví dụ là sắp Jack
là gì hay ở thậm chí body là gì Cái kiểu
như thế này sẽ là một Hãy CC là gì luôn
như thế này đã nhận thức ra mình không
thèm quan tâm nữa đấy mình sẽ ví dụ các
bạn thôi Bấm vào đây này Nó sẽ mở bằng
ứng dụng mail ra đồng loại
cái bấm vào thẻ A để copy thì nó lại là
phải toán khác nó sẽ dùng ra Speed để
làm điều này anh không thể dùng thể làm
việc được từ nay về sau các bạn các bạn
Thể tra là dùng ra Swift copy thì các
bạn sẽ ra được vấn đề không ạ
a
tiếp theo như mình đã nói cái đề cập lại
với cái vụ Facebook đúng mà mình muốn mở
nó bằng cái app của Facebook cơ thì các
bạn sẽ tra như sau
sẽ là Open app Facebook trở lại
thì ra là tình yêu cha cũng sẽ ra đấy
Các
bạn thấy hạnh Facebook như này thế bạn
thấy gì đâu ạ
Ừ cái mình không nhớ lắm đâu
Facebook bếp Tết thì bạn biết đi à
em thử xem nhé để điện Bình thủ xác và
ok ok này sẽ stress không
đây để mình thử
mình nhớ mình từng hư rồi mình nhá mình
tiếng rồi à
từ ngày con trai rồi
bố ủa ai
Đợi mình tính à
anh
Alo Alo ạ
ờ ờ
À chắc là phải truyền hình vô file này
để mình thử biệt thự
Bộ Quốc phòng iPad Poli không Mình nhớ
hồi để góp cho được cả
Android mình khẳng định luôn bởi vì hôi
đến mình có ấy đâu mình dùng Android mà
thử nhé Không thử sao biết
Tuy nhiên bấm ở trên này thì méo không
thấy ra gì Thôi nhá mà thôi Tôi nghĩ là
chắc là tôi sẽ thử đây ở dưới này đây
Cặp đôi này à
anh đúng không
Nói chung là cái này nó chạy được nhưng
mà bây giờ tôi đang ở trên trên máy tính
màn đúng không nên bấm có công tác dụng
gì cả nhưng mà nhưng mà Mấy ông hiểu gì
tôi mà ông ạ nghĩa là hoàn toàn bấm cái
này để nhảy sang không phải mỗi đường
link Ý tôi là thế không phải mỗi đường
link mà bấm để mở hẳn trong áp
bởi vì thực tế là các bạn hoàn toàn hệ
nhận diện được quét các bạn hãy nhận
diện được là các bạn đang on bằng điện
thoại hay là máy tính thì để mà hiển thị
ra được cái đường link để người dùng bấm
vào thật chế non biết được hệ điều hành
các bạn đang dùng cơ Thế mà toàn hệ biết
được các bạn dùng is thì ok thì mở có
cái đường Linh tạo ra mở cổng ai hết
giống vừa vừa thôi Ông này bảo đúng
không ạ với is thì nhà với Android như
thế nào vẫn bật nó ngoác nữa Mở link
trong tab ẩn danh nhá Khi nó thực ra nó
luôn hỏi lại có ông là có ông cũng muốn
mời bằng áp hay không ạ
ừ ừ
Vì thế nên là tôi Tôi nghĩ là mày ông
cũng hiểu ý tôi thì hoàn toàn là tôi có
thể mở cái này bằng istar này YouTube
này các thử sẽ là ngon hay thì bấm vào
đường link nó sẽ mở ra trên trình duyệt
Họ sẽ rất là khó chịu
đúng là đôi khi ở đấy Đấy là theo kiểu
là
còn đi nào điện thoại thông minh hoặc là
hoặc là
nói chung Hoàng kiểu tôi nghĩa là phải
do bằng điện thoại nó hỗ trợ vụ lại tự
mở bằng áp lạnh thể bởi vì đường link và
hỗ trợ đúng không ạ
à à
anh không Em 12 chuyển sang chế độ di
động thì thời ta thử 500 tác dụng gì cả
Bởi vì bản chất là mình đã cài mấy cái
app này trên máy của mình đâu đúng không
ạ trên máy này có cái đâu mà giống như
kiểu cái mail này nó khác cái mail này
chị chắc chắn là kiểu nó trên cả máy
tính và cả điện thoại thì có thể có thể
mở bằng áp được
Lê Minh hoàn toàn có thể bắt được cái
việc và người dùng đang dùng cái gì sau
đó thì để hiển thị ra đúng cái đúng cái
IQ này hợp với cái cái kẹo người dùng
đang dùng trừ khi người dùng theo kiểu
là giả khéo bạn đang dùng Android như
kiểu bạn là fan Apple nữa bạn vẫn dùng
giả Apple ra hệ điều hành khách các thứ
thứ về thì dẫn cung mỗi hỗ trợ dai lấy
việc các bạn đúng không
ngờ Mấy ông nãy giờ chả hiểu gì tôi rồi
để chữa xong một cái câu thế a a
à à
ờ ờ
ở đó thì hôm nay sẽ sang bài hôm Ánh mày
ông chuẩn bị đừng có giúp mình nhé đầu
tiên đêm một cái đầu tiên thì hôm nay
bài Sẽ Về form giống như là tôi có để ở
đây hôm nay mình trả lời câu hỏi bộ
trước này phạm mà chia sẻ kiến thức mới
tiếc mới thì hôm nay sẽ có 2 mục mình sẽ
đề cập sau
từ
nãy giờ vào học rồi đấy chứ Đấy là đang
trả lời câu hỏi và học mà ừ
ở
đây cái phone này form này phom của
thằng Facebook nếu mà Mấy ông để kỹ là
hồi trước là thằng Facebook nộp vậy kể
từ ở đây nó là
qm oyz phải gọi với tôi tôi chỉ nhớ được
cái ý đại khái của nó là kiểu miễn phí
và mãi mãi vậy còn bây giờ nó đã sửa lại
câu bộ đó chứng tỏ là nó không có miễn
phí nữa Đúng rồi thực tế là Facebook mà
miễn phí nhưng thời gian đón thu thập
thông tin của ông ấy bán lấy tiền thưởng
thứ Nên là thực sự nó đang đứng yên đó
dầu lên chứ nhờ mấy ông mày sẽ chả Nội
không ạ Ừ thế là nhưng mà nó không dùng
được cái câu + miễn phí cái xử nữa
à Nói chung cái pho ở đây các bạn sẽ
thấy nó là cái form rất là cơ bản ngoa
điền tên họ tên sau đó thì số điện thoại
rồi Mật khẩu này
hai con hình như nó không cho nhập lại
mật khẩu Kiểu cái xác thực hơi vớ vẩn
sau đó đi ngày tháng năm sinh nè Đó
ngoan giới tính này Đấy đây một form cơ
bản tiếp theo mình sẽ cho các bạn thêm
xem thêm một vài for nữa mà ông Đừng
giật mình nhé
ở
đây Đây là một con khác có mày không rất
là cơ bản như các bạn thấy là cùng là
không đăng ký nhưng mà nó hiển thị kiểu
nó có nó thu hợp ít thông tin hơn bởi
Đây là một trang web nhảy cặp cho phép
này tôi vừa phải mở và ngẩn dàng kết hợp
với phải mẫu VPN lên được vào
Ê mấy ông thực đường cổ đoàn nó diện của
nó à
Ừ đấy Thì đại khái đây là trang web về
đăng ký không ạ thì các bạn thấy nó sẽ
chỉ cần điền email để mà cậu email
Thường ơi kiểu để gửi gửi spam quảng cáo
như là để mãi về sau xác thực như là mật
khẩu đúng không Không cần tên của cái
ông ở đây tiếp theo là một cái web khác
quét này của chẳng cần đăng nhập máy mài
ông chỉ cần bật tên và tên bất cứ cái gì
cũng được bà để ông bình luận ông không
có đăng nhập thì cả
số trang web này đương nhiên là nhưng
tôi vừa nói thì thì cũng phải mở ẩn danh
nữa đã mở bằng ghen à
a tiếp theo nhá
mà ghép này với mày thì tôi đã vừa phải
xóa bớt tên nữa Tự nhiên Tây mà nó có
trong đây nhưng mà chắc là mấy ông không
ra lúc đâu
Ừ
đấy thì web này thì mấy ông như mấy ông
thấy bởi vì đây là mày kế web kiểu nó
thông tin nóng nhạy cảm anh thành ra là
không cần bệnh viện điện kiểu Tên thật
của bạn là gì trong ngày sinh hay giới
tính của bạn ở gì cả chỉ cần email và
các bạn muốn hiển thị tên nó là gì không
ạ Thế là được
số 15 để chẳng đến 15 vị đấy ở
đây mấy ông cha là hình dung được mấy
cái chỗ phom rồi đúng không ạ
à à
anh
nói chung là mấy ông vừa rồi hình dung
được cái form nó không ạ thì em à for
này không phải là toàn bộ cái for mà tôi
đang đề cập
cái form ở đây nó là bao gồm việc mà các
bạn có thể lên trang Google nhưng lại
các bạn Gõ mở gì đó nhà ảnh gái xinh ở
đây không chưa có vẻ như thế này Đấy cái
này bạn chất Nó là một cái from đúng mà
các bạn Nhập cái gì đó từ bàn phím nó nó
sẽ luôn còn phải các bạn Nhập giống như
các bạn đang ngồi Star mở kia đó là
report kênh không thông báo với thể điệu
chưa họ mẹ Vân Vân hoặc Báo công an này
màn chất các bạn cũng đang điền cái form
đồng ngoài cái form nó chẳng cần đăng ký
gì cả nó chỉ một form với các bạn Nhập
vào và các bạn là inter để gửi nó đi
không ạ thì tất cả phải đồng đấy nó là
form thì các bạn sẽ thấy các bạn thao
tác với for us Ừ từ việc là nhắn tin này
sau đó đi tìm kiếm này sau đó thì bình
luận này đúng không ạ chỉ có Thậm chí
các bạn đăng ảnh Đăng ảnh thì các bạn sẽ
cũng cũng cũng sẽ là for thôi đúng không
ạ Bạn đăng ảnh đại diện hay gì đó chỉ
các bạn ấn like mà các bạn chắn chẳng
nhập thêm cái gì từ bàn phím thì nó
không phải là phom còn đâu thì các bạn
làm việc với form rất nhiều thế nên là
hôm nay sẽ học về cái đấy đâu ạ ạ
Ừ Tự nhiên tôi thấy mấy ông tương tác
nha nhé Mấy ông chỉ tiêm bác mình có lẽ
nhanh thôi thế là dở rồi à
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ đấy thì để mà mình dậy cho các bạn nếu
như là for phải nên tổng quát nhất em
mình sẽ lấy cái ví dụ này đúng không ạ
đem cái for khá tổng quát
ừ ừ
Ừ thì for này các bạn thấy for này còn
hai điểm và mình dùng trình cái ảnh này
nó kết hợp cả thầy bùa nữa các bạn sẽ để
ý đây một cái Thay bồ đâu mà Bởi vì à Nó
có viền này kết hợp việc nó có hai cột
này riêng cái trên cùng và cái dưới cung
mà nó sẽ gặp lại đúng không
ừ ừ
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ kiểu thấy là điền thông
tin như thế này mình sẽ dậy mà cho buổi
hôm nay mình sẽ dạy các bạn làm điền đầy
đủ tất cả thông tin như này này
ở đầu tiên thì để các bạn làm việc với
thể for mà đương nhiên là nó là thẻ for
đúng không ạ phải có một cái thẻ thì nó
sẽ form và trong và bắt buộc phải có thể
for này là thứ nhất thứ hai là toàn bộ
những cái thông tin những cái để nhập
nhập này là bắt buộc phải nằm trong thẻ
alt thì mới được
thì for mày ra sự mình đều tiên mình
điện họ tên em ạ để điền họ tên thì mình
cần có của o để nhập đúng không Thì ô
đấy sẽ gọi là Oh in phút và nhập tên thì
mình sẽ phải nhập được cả chữ chắc cháu
là chữ ở ngoài với chữ có dấu cái hư thứ
thì sẽ khái niệm bằng nhập thay sẽ là
tách như thế này đều ngoan ý
a tiếp theo là mình sẽ xuống lòng đi em
mình cứ thử chạy thử các bạn xem nhé
ở đại điện họ tên này đúng không ạ sự
như này sự đây là mẹ nào Long đã
nhưng mà đương nhiên là cái otek này có
bị nhược điểm một tí đó là khó nhập được
cả chữ cả số các kí tự đặc biệt và văn
văn
Bạn chí và các bạn Nhập chỉ có mỗi dấu
cách được đấy nhớ là cái cái vụ để mà
kiểm tra xem tên nó nhập hợp lệ không ấy
thì có bạn về sau phải sang Học giống
như đầu buổi mình có nói là các bạn sẽ
phải Đợi mình tí được chị ạ
à à
ờ ờ
Ừ đúng rồi Mình chưa dậy thể đi đâu
Không phải mình quên đâu nhá mình không
quên mà sang bên CS thì mình sẽ dạy đi
không ạ Đúng rồi bạn kia nói chuyện cái
đít và cụ thế khuya Trizzie và hát Đức
nhân nghĩa là HTML ở những ý là
sang bên xe thì các bạn ấy mới kiểu mới
hiểu thực sự đít để làm gì nếu mà không
thì các bạn Thực tế là đít với thể p từ
ra nó không khác gì nhau Sự thật là như
thế chẳng qua là người ta dùng như thế
nào thôi đi với thì p nó cũng chẳng khác
gì nhau
nhưng mà thôi phạm được trong quay lại
bàn nha Mình có họ tên đúng à
anh không thể T không phải span span thì
nó sẽ không không được bằng đít
Ờ họ tên này rồi Tiếp theo là
anh
số điện thoại đi số điện thoại tại sao
mình để cập số điện thoại Bởi vì rất là
nó sẽ khác với họ tên là mình nhập được
Có dấu hai chữ các thư kí tự đặc biệt
chỉ số điện thoại thì đương nhiên chị
nhập số chẳng hạn không ạ thì mình sẽ có
một cái nút mà hai nó sẽ là number đấy
để nhập khẩu địa chỉ là nhập
số thôi đúng không còn tiếp theo nữa là
sửa là trong trong một cái pho đăng ký
thì sẽ có phải email không ạ thì mình sẽ
là nhập email như thế này
và mình sẽ mình mình mình cho cái nút
nút trước đi mình sẽ cho nó 1 cái nút để
mà
nó sẽ lại in phút này anh trai là submit
này để mà khi mà mình
chưa Mình điện xong hết Xong thì nó sẽ
gửi cái phone đi em ạ sẽ như thế này
thì tại sao tự nhiên mình phải đề cập có
cái nút sớm như thế bởi vì là là sự là
mình Điền họ tên Đây là Nghĩa năm rồi ạ
Như này cái gì đó sau đó số điện thoại
thì mình không nhập được Chữ nhé mình
đang cố nghiệp chữ thì cái thứ nhất mình
nhập cái chữ chữ e thôi chữ em lại nhận
chỉ nhập được một lần em như mùi 10 mũ
bao nhiêu em bị không nhớ còn ai bên
toán học nếu mà ừ
á cái nem cái cả nên về sau các bạn học
xong pp để bởi áp dụng đây mình sẽ không
đề cập ở đây mình sẽ tạm xóa đi nên các
bạn thấy em mình lâu mình gõ ra nó luôn
hiển thị ra một cánh nhọn nêm đó ngon
thay nè nêm này cho mình luôn xoa cái
nên đi của về sau các bạn với áp dụng ờ
cho số điện thoại này ra sự bên thì mình
sẽ chỉ được nhập số và cả nhập là -2 +
gì nó trong này đấy thì nó cũng tương
đối tương đối là chuẩn chẳng hạn đối
ngoại đi
ờ
ờ tiếp theo Đến email đúng không ạ thì
cái email là mình các bạn sẽ thấy sự can
nó nhập được mọi thứ tự thật chứ cả dấu
cách ra rẽ sai rồi xong rồi các kí tự
đặc biệt như này nữa nhập ở rất nhiều
như thế này các bạn sẽ thắc mắc là à
Ừ thế kỷ email này nó khắc gì về u-tech
đúng không Nhưng mà khi mà mục các bạn
bấm sắp ít này Đấy do mà phải có cái bấm
như này để các bạn thực sự các bạn khi
học đó là riêng cái thằng hay là Email
thì nó sẽ phải HTML nó sẽ tự động vay
bếp và nó kiểm tra CellphoneS nhập đúng
hay sai và đây nó sẽ báo lỗi là sẽ dàn
email này không hợp lệ Cách để mày email
tục lệ đương nhiên là sẽ ra kẹo à Còn
mail như này đại khái như thế này thì nó
mới hợp lệ để không ạ mà đương như à Các
bạn thấy là mỗi khi mình bấm xong
bấm xong ấy nó gần nhiên nó lại trang
không phải nó lại cho anh đâu Chẳng qua
muốn đẩy thông tin toàn bộ thông tin và
các bạn điền trong iPhone nó sẽ đẩy đi
đẩy lên một con server gì đó để lưu lại
thông tin tạm thời bây giờ nó rảnh đẩy
đi đâu cả bởi vì em mình chưa điềm gì
xong lại cả cái đấy sau dậy xanh TP rồi
các bạn sẽ biết
à à
Ờ Ờ bạn kia nhắc lại với típ và p khác
nhau anh đi và PC khác nhau về cái bát
Đinh Thực ra người ta không không phân
biệt đi với PC qua mỗi ba đình thôi Nên
như mình đang nói thì người ta chẳng qua
người ta thích dùng ít thôi
và thể PR Cho đoạn văn mà không đúng lắm
cái này là nó quý ốc cảm như thế nhưng
mà thời gian áp dụng cho bất cứ cái gì
được
nhưng nói chung là mình kiểu gì về sao
mình sẽ dậy đít khi mà sẽ chạy sang bên
CS ở ngoại ô
ở
bên xuống ở ô số điện thoại làm như thế
nào trải qua nó là thẻ in input number
nên mặc định nó sẽ luôn có cái hiển thị
lên xuống này các bạn tăng giảm số thôi
có bạn thì đang nói mình dùng thể lấy bù
nhưng thực ra cái này không phải là cái
kiểu cái kiểu kiến thức cơ bản mình sẽ
không đề cập các bạn về mấy cái đấy Ở
đây ạ
à à
Ừ ok thì tiếp theo mình sẽ tiếp nhé nếu
các bạn thấy thắc mắc rồi mình tiếp tục
dậy rồi à à
a tiếp theo là mình sẽ có đơn giản ạ
nhập email của nhập password nữa đóng
ngoặc nhận bật khóc
yêu cũ hay password này
ấy chỉ riêng cái mật khẩu này nó sẽ là
kiểu đương như các bạn Nhập hoàn toàn ký
tự bao nhiêu kí tự đặc biệt trong ngày
cũng được nhưng nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ biến
kiệm ngay đúng không nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ ẩn
đi các bạn thì ra đây là cúng làm bị một
cái gọi những điểm ấy bởi vì các bạn mà
thì các bạn mặc kiểu dạng là các bạn lưu
lại mật khẩu trên máy các bạn đấy Đúng
ngoan không sự thật như thế các bạn lưu
lại mật khẩu trên máy các bạn Sau đó thì
các bạn vào vào ô nhập in bút đúng không
Ở
đây chẳng em mình nói cho các bạn xem
mật khẩu của mình để mình nhớ xem cái
trang là một khẩu mình không quan trọng
Tại mình tí ở đây đây gần đây vừa mới
còn đây
Từ
ngày ông là thích hjh ah
à à
anh em mình sẽ để mua các bạn tay ra sự
mình có tranh này đúng không ạ
anh sữa như này
à à à
a123 này đã sử và sự nhập như này đúng
không ạ sau đó thì mình hoàn toàn Thế An
It's ra xử là khi mà các bạn khi chọn và
mấy cái kiểu như này để nó tự động Điền
này qua tự động Điền luôn cả mật khẩu
Này các bạn nói toàn ấn F12 Chắc là
nhiều bạn biết cái này rồi thì các bạn
thấy cái sai nó mật khẩu các bạn Xóa đi
này hiểu sẽ hiển thị ra mật khẩu chuẩn
za ở đây đúng không khi cái cái cái khi
mà có xóa sai đi nó sẽ tương đương với
thay mặc định bằng cách nên nó sẽ hiển
thị mật khẩu lên Thế nên là mục khi mà
ông nào mà kiểu Ấn lưu lại mật khẩu ở
trên trình duyệt sau đó thì mẹ ông cậy
là kiểu bấm vào đây xong rồi để mà thằng
kia biết rồi mật khẩu của mình bấm vào
đây để xem mật khẩu ngay chẳng hạn nó sẽ
luôn phải hỏi lại mật khẩu máy tính mà
thằng kia đâu biết máy tính mật khẩu máy
tính mình là gì đâu đúng không Thì nó sẽ
không nổ được không Nó sẽ vào thử cái
trang web like sau đó thì nó sẽ ấn tự
động Điền mật khẩu cho nó thì nó chỉ cần
ấn F12 để bể đổi giống như vừa rồi thì
nó sẽ xem 3 4 thôi đúng không em
à à
Em hãy thế thành ra là mấy ông đừng có
chia sẻ hẳn cái máy tính cho người ta mà
không không quản lý nhé không ạ ạ
a tiếp theo là mật khẩu xong rồi này
à à
em nhập lại mật khẩu mấy ông sẽ nghĩ là
cái nhập lại mật khẩu này là đương nhiên
để kiểm tra hai thằng mật khẩu vừa mới
nhập lại mật khẩu nhà nhập lại ở trong
này hai thằng phải khớp nhau không ạ
Và sẽ nghĩ là phải dùng cái công nghệ gì
đó Đương nhiên cái này sẽ dùng ra Swift
để kiểm tra xem hai thằng là khớp nhau
không chứ không phải dùng HTML để làm
điều đấy thành ra là cái cái cái không
có thẻ nào cho cái này chị ăn là thẻ này
sẽ phát quốc thôi
tiếp theo nữa giới tính các bạn sẽ thấy
giới tính ở đây nó sẽ mặc định nó sẽ chị
luôn hai lựa chọn các bạn thì các bạn
chọn thì cái này nó không phải là cái
thứ để nhập mà cái thứ này cái thứ thể
tích cả đúng không ạ thì mình sẽ đi Ở
đây giả sử mình cũng chỉ có hai giờ thì
nhưng mà được tính nhé mình sẽ có in Bút
nó cũng lại nút ra bản chất nó sẽ là
chết Bốc như thế này thì các bạn sẽ điên
à Việt Nam
phụ nữ này nha chị ạ
Mẹ bị xuống dòng đi
đấy thì có bạn sẽ thấy nó kiện như này
các bạn sẽ thấy ở giao diện nó khác với
cái giao diện này đúng không Bởi vì thực
tế là cái ra chuyện này giao diện cũng
là HTML đấy chắc chắn đều HTML thôi
nhưng mà cái giao diện này rất hiện thực
cũng lâu rồi và cái này còn liên quan cả
trình duyệt nữa các bạn mà copy cái file
này chạy trên Internet Explorer
thì nó sẽ hiển thị ra khác
Ừ tao sẽ luôn lấy mày làm ví dụ
Ừ cái kiểu như này các bạn hãy thứ cao
nó khác lá rồi không ạ Con gì thì ra
kiểu sắp mcquarrie xăm Cười cái gì anh
nói kiểu như thế à
Ừ mà tự nha các bạn chạy trên Firefox
hay chạy trên hết hay là nhiều cái trình
duyệt khác nó Sẽ định kiểu khác
ở đây à
Ừ thì mặt nhưng mà cái bản chất là nó sẽ
vẫn sẽ giống nhau đúng không ạ
Ờ Ờ
bây giờ nhưng mà ở đây có vị nhược điểm
một tí đó là mình tích vào đây mình tích
cực vào đây hai như thế là sai mới ngồi
không ạ
Ừ thì bạn chất ở đây là mình Nếu mình
tích ở giới tính thì chị chọn một trong
hai thôi tôi đang không nói trường hợp
là ông nào lưỡng tính hay các thử nhé
Nhớ là chuẩn đúng giới tính thì chỉ chọn
một trong hai thì thì mình sẽ phải cho
nó ở đây mình để cái nêm Ở đây có lý do
cả các bạn phải để đây một cái nêm anh
em nhầm dùng Rio Xin lỗi Xin lỗi mình
quên quên quyền tạo nháo quá Alo
Xin lỗi Xin lỗi
Em đừng có trách bốc phải đúng là thích
được cả hai Rio là thích được một quên
quên đấy đấy giao diện tương đồng như
này đúng không ạ
cho mình mình sẽ lỗi Xin lỗi lâu không
dậy nháo quá
nhưng mà bạn Chắc là bây giờ mình tích
này vẫn tích ở cả hai thôi bây bây giờ
mình muốn mình muốn để cho chỉ được tích
từ một đấy thì cái nêm của nó bắt buộc
phải có và phải giống nhau
vẫn đúng rồi Rio vẫn tích được cả hai
Nếu các bạn không để cho nó cái nêm thì
bây giờ cái nêm này này các bạn thở ra
các bạn đặt nó là cái gì cũng được nhờ
giả sự đây cũng là ai chẳng ạ thì các
bạn sẽ thấy là nó sẽ chỉ thích là một
Nhưng thực tế là các bạn không nên đặt
tên vô nghĩa như thế mà các bạn bây giờ
là gần như là dòng Nó để nói về sau các
bạn còn lập trình dựa trên cái nêm ấy
nữa nhưng các bạn phải đặt tên gì đó
Kiểu như mình đã từng nói là tên kẹo kéo
chuẩn ở đó nghĩa không nên có dấu mà
không nên có dấu cách luôn mà phải là
một là tiếng Anh hoàn toàn hai tiếng
Việt hoàn toàn và viết theo kiểu là một
hoặc bà a nhớ các bạn nhiều không ạ một
là gạch dưới kiểu là con rắn hai câu lặc
bà nhé nghe này đúng không ạ thì giới
tính sẽ như thế
thế giới tính ở đây nó đi xuất ý luôn
cho mình này cho mình gõ nhiều rồi
anh đấy à
anh sex cận các bạn nên dùng render 2
Vietsub I
thì nó phải chung một cái nêm bởi vì là
nếu mà không chung nêm vì thực ra thì ở
dưới này các bạn có
ở đại liên từ mình ra lấy mình bà bạn đã
lấy đổi ý
anh bởi vì là không không hỏi lát đâu
Tại mình vừa mới bảo kia thì
anh bởi bởi vì là nếu mà không có input
radio mà có nên rộng giống nhau hết thì
ở dưới Giả sử vào thêm một vài cái nút
nữa cũng ở radio thì các bạn sẽ sẽ kiểu
như này đây mình thử ví dụ các bạn
xe đẩy dụng là lớp sáng ạ
họ lập trình ở
Cơ sở Quảng Trị này
nếu các bạn không để nêm cho nó bất kỳ
cái gì như thế này thì rõ ràng là ạ Các
bạn ở trên này các bạn muốn tích một
trong hai nhưng ở dưới này các bạn muốn
tích ngồi trong hai đúng ạ thì làm sao
nó phân biệt được đúng không nó không
biết được cái hàng ngày nó là của thằng
ở dưới rồi Cả ngày nằm không có chuyện
là hai thằng cạnh nhau với nó sẽ thuộc
với nhau không không không không làm
trước đấy mà bắt buộc nó phải có quyền
nêm cho nó hai thằng nêm giống nhau giới
thiệu nói của nhau họ sẽ không Anh Hưởng
cái thằng dưới mình tích được Khánh dưới
nó cũng không ảnh hưởng thành trên đúng
hoặc đấy do là mình bắt buộc phải nêm
như thế thôi à
khi
tẩy xong rồi Tiếp theo mình sẽ nhảy sang
thêm cái về ngày sinh ngày sinh này thì
mình sẽ khác với cái ông đang để ở đây
một tí cho dù là ngày sinh nhật mình
thấy bây giờ ít người dùng theo cái này
mà người ta dùng theo cách kiểu như này
hơn hoặc giống như thằng Facebook lúc
nào mình mở ấy sẽ chia ra nhiều cái sân
nhưng mà Ngày sinh của mình mình dậy
chuẩn dạy cho các bạn để các bạn biết
qua thì nó sẽ là kiểu biết ngoặc tạm xóa
nên tiếp đi này
đấy thì cái này là đang theo trên máy
của mình máy mình đang để nó là ngày
tháng năm nên đây sẽ là ngày tháng năm
nhưng mà cái thái một mình là kiểu chữ
thành ra nó sẽ như thế này đấy các bạn
sẽ thấy nó là kiểu ngay nghĩa là nếu
mình để tiếng Việt thì nó sẽ theo tiếng
Việt nhảy kiểu thế Do cái Trinh diệt nó
theo cái giờ giấc của máy nữa ừ ừ
à à Ừ thì cài input date lại nó kiểu như
thế Các bạn thấy thôi Cái này bị nhược
điểm một tí đó là kiểu các bạn bây giờ
sự mình chọn cái mình sinh năm 1997 là
mạng thì các bạn thấy là mình sẽ rất là
mất công để mất bao nhiêu cái click để
xô ngồi cuộn chuột để mà bấm nào dụng
mình 9 tháng 1 này mùng 1 tháng 1 đấy
thì các bạn thấy mình mất rất nhiều cái
click để để mà kiểu làm để mà chọn được
mỗi ngày sinh của mình thế nên là người
dùng đôi khi người dùng sẽ không thích
cái này mà người dùng sẽ thích cái kiểu
theo quy tắc như hai cái bây giờ để làm
cái kiểu như thế này là sự mình sẽ có ví
dụ nữa nhưng lần này không phải ngày
sinh mà mình sẽ cho là ví dụ lớp học cả
năm rộ đăng ký vào lớp không ạ
ở lớp này khi nó sẽ khái niệm là select
options cháu ạ
em học sinh ở đây sẽ là
lập trình
quản trị này
boxing ạ
Đấy thi mình mình mỗi lần mình làm xong
đây như mình và tả lại tra nữa thì nó
lại mất hết toàn bộ rồi
thì ở đây các bạn nó sẽ thấy nó sẽ
select này axit cũng chỉ chọn được một
giống cái thằng Rio này nhá Nó hiển thị
ra cỡ như này
Ừ tí tí mình cuối buổi mình sẽ nói các
bạn Phân tích kỹ hơn về cái vụ là lúc
nào nên dùng lái Ô lúc nào nên dùng kéo
dây option để Ngoại Ô
Ừ
đấy tiếp theo là giả sự là bây giờ các
bạn thấy hoàn toàn nãy giờ nhưng cái Tại
sao lại có những cái tích kiểu như thế
này
ở những cái Chọn nhanh như này là để cho
người dùng đỡ mất công nhập không ạ Nó
sẽ hiển thị ra và giới hạn cái lượt lựa
chọn của người dùng và người dùng máy ép
phải một trăm ba cái này F1 trong hai
cái này đúng không ạ Không phải là có
trường hợp là kiểu người dùng nhập làm
cái gì đó mà kiểu Tao muốn học ví dụ là
muốn vẽ này môn gì gì đó nữa Muốn bơi
lội cả bạn tự nhiên trường ta không có
Nhưng mà tao thích nhập vào lớp bơi lội
đấy rồi Thế thì không được ngon thì bắt
buộc của chị chọn một trong đó ngày thôi
thì thế nên là nó phù hợp cho việc áp
dụng xe lách ở đây hơn làm cái ô input
a tiếp theo là giả sử mình có một cái sở
thích đi đúng không
cơ sở thích chúng ta giờ này sở thích
mình không muốn là kiểu chỉ cố định như
thế này không ạ Mình sẽ có sở thích là
kẹo lấy hoạt tím mình thích nhiều cái mà
không ạ thì thấy mình sẽ có khái niệm là
chết bóc ra này chắc bóp này
trước bóc
lại xem phim đúng không
nghe nhạc
Hôm này lành lại mạnh nhé
nhảy dây đi cho lành mạnh tôi sẽ khi ạ
Có khi nào sẽ giải thích cậu cái vụ nhảy
dây nó lành mạnh nha à
ờ ờ đánh thì cái này hoàn toàn thể tích
được nhiều tất cả có thể là thận chứa
các bạn không thích cũng được kiểu kiểu
như thế nó ngoác thích thì nhiều
ừ ừ
à à
Ê mấy ông đã bảo lần này lành mạnh được
nếu mà bấm Nhau Đi
Ừ đấy tiếp theo là đến vụ hiển thị ra
chọn file ảnh đại diện đúng không Thì
mình sẽ có ảnh đại diện
mình sẽ có một cái nút là file ngay để
chọn một cái file chương trình đó
Đương nhiên là về sau mình có thể mình
mình đang chỉ nói qua các bạn phải cơ
bản rồi tí là sẽ nâng cao thêm cho đồng
này nhá
là theo kiểu là các bạn chỉ được phép
chọn anh ấy chị gửi cho phép chọn file
Excel Vân thì sẽ như thế nào
để
thầy thử để lê mặc không cái thể loại
trước bộ phim thì các bạn để nêm cho nó
đứng như về sau cài ô nào các bạn cũng
sẽ phải để nêm nó thôi Nhưng mà nếu mà
để nên trùng nó nó với bộ sở thích em ạ
thì nó cũng sẽ thích được nhiều thôi tại
như này thích được nhiều thôi ông ạ ạ
Anh
Tạm Thời bây giờ mình không dùng em mình
cũng có đi đã Nhưng mà bây giờ tính bắt
buộc phải có thì nó mới tí cho chị một
nó ngoan
đấy Anh đại diện Mình sẽ bấm vào đây để
chọn file cái này các bạn thấy rồi và
các bạn thấy rõ ràng giao diện nó sẽ
khác với giao diện đây đúng không ạ À
cái này giống
cũng tương đối giống giống rồi
thế nhưng sẽ có bài tập mình sẽ gửi các
bạn nó có thể khác đấy
tiếp theo nữa là gần như cuối vậy nhưng
không làm cuối rồi giờ Sửa mô tả bản
thân em ạ mô tả bạn thân
kiểu như này kiểu quá trình hình thành
và phát triển của bản thân em không ạ
thì cái này là hoàn toàn ở không thể mục
Ôi nút kiểu như này không xuống dòng
được mà nó giống như là cả một bài văn
tế một cái nói chung là một cái bài đăng
của các bạn lại các bạn mô tả rất nhiều
thế nên là nó sẽ để nên để trong một cái
gọi tách alio đây là hơi đặc biệt một tí
bởi vì à
Nó hoàn toàn thể kéo ra như này Thoải
mái này để các bạn Nhập vào bạn sẽ thấy
nó không thể màu mè được giống như là
kiểu
áo len moma theo cậu là kiểu có thể nhập
ký tự có thể chọn kí tự đặc biệt ở đây
hay là cậu cho nó in đậm hay in nghiêng
gì đó giống như word thì các bạn thấy có
một vài trang làm được vụ đấy Chẳng qua
là nó ôm một cái plug-in một cái kẹo
tiện ích khác về đèo ngoạn còn Thuận te
quiero nó sẽ chỉ như thế này thôi nó sẽ
nhập được rất nhiều sao nó gọi em tơ
chúng ra mời các bạn vì nó rõ ngoan
địa chỉ địa chỉ các bạn Nhập vào trong
cái te quiero cũng được nhớ thường mà
mình thấy thì các bạn sẽ tắt rocker mình
thấy rất nhiều nơi nó sẽ tách ra rồi cậu
lại các bạn Nhập số nhà để trong cái in
bút còn toàn bộ những cái cậu phố này
Cuộn này thành phố và Vân thậm chí ở
quốc gia này sẽ trong sẽ lawson ừ ừ
Ừ để cho Tránh trường hợp chọn nhập linh
tinh đúng không ạ
ở đó Nói chung à Đây à Đúng rồi còn thêm
một cái nữa các bạn sẽ biết là khái niệm
Inbox hay là reset reset là cái reset là
điểm gì để mặc kiểu các bạn mà điền xong
rồi nhưng các bạn cậu ấy chán tao61 đăng
ký nữa mà tao điên sai nhiều quá Tao
muốn nhập lại từ đầu ta sẽ ấn nút chia
sẻ Xóa toàn bộ đi không hoa nở Xóa toàn
bộ đi mà Khôi phục lại cài phom ban đầu
về phẩm ban đầu của nó ra sự biện Sẵn
thông tin rồi mà tích hộ Ông ấy tính rồi
em đã tích hộ âm đấy nhảy dây rồi chả
nhãn ông reset ông Quay lại cái dây
không ạ
ừ
thì
nãy giờ là cái cơ bản các bạn nhiều ông
ở đây tôi thấy nhiều ông nãy giờ hỏi
toàn câu cậu cáo siêu chắc là mấy ông
thấy nó dễ quá rồi
Ờ thế nên là bây giờ tôi sẽ dạy
chứ không phải nâng cao mà dậy sâu hơn
một tí và để mấy ông đỡ thấy chán thì
bài tập về sẽ có họa cuối tuần rồi mà
ông ngồi làm bài tập đi
Ờ thì đầu tiên ở đây nha đầu tiên ở đây
các bạn sẽ thấy là cái ở đây này nó có
hiển thị ra cái chữ ở đây chữ này chữ
vẫn ý thôi và các bạn Nhập vào thì nó sẽ
bị biến mất thì ở đây là sẽ là khái niệm
lây hồ sơ như thế này dụng là điền họ
điền
tên bạn ở đây các bạn
ấy
thì nó sẽ
gợi ý là đầy đúng không ạ
à à
đề thi các bạn cứ đi ăn cái gì đó đây
thì nó sẽ xóa mất cái từ ấy đi ông ạ
Vâng order này mình nhớ mình nhớ không
làm là nó không áp dụng được cho mấy cái
kẹo thằng này thì phải thư pháp
Em à bây giờ áp dụng được rồi đấy nón
thôi hồi hồi mình ngồi mình dậy nó không
áp dụng được thế được các bạn hoàn toàn
thể cho lấy hồi đầu vào đây nữa Ngoài ra
còn thêm những cái gì nữa nó có ở hết
mấy cái liên quan đến sai nè trở lại ở
kích kích thước sửa là số điện thoại
hoặc đôi khi ở các bạn điền mã mã mã bưu
điện này mà bưu điện thì ra là cái cái ô
là nhắm mắt các bạn có thể cho xay = 50
- ạ
anh sai nhỉ
à À đúng rồi sau này mới không áp dụng
cho năm bờ này sai áp dụng cái này vậy
đấy Đúng rồi chỉ các bạn phải điền nha
thì các bạn sẽ thắc mắc à sai mà không
điện nó bời thì em thấy có vài trang web
sẽ ra là điến nó chỉ được đếm số mà rõ
ràng cột nó bé lắm thì cái sai này các
bạn phải can thiệp bạn chat bằng sẽ thôi
à
Khi sáng mấy giờ ông bảo chưa học được
bạn chưa học được gì nhiều
thế bây giờ rồi đối với người mới nãy
giờ một đống thẻ thì sao chết thì
du lịch học
Lịch học thì là
35737 vào là học web còn thứ năm là học
về SQL cái này chat là nếu bạn chắc
không ở trong this code của mình chắc là
phải thi thoảng để ý nghĩa qua kênh của
mình nhờ ấn vào cái Tab là community
cộng đồng ấy các bạn xem bài đăng 1 mình
thông báo nhé ạ
anh ở đây còn người biết rồi Không sao
mình dạy cho cả tất cả những người thậm
chí A có nghề ông sẽ không biết mà không
ạ sử ở đây số điện thoại nó có thể hoàn
toàn thì Minmax cho nó nữa là ví dụ mình
chỉ muốn tối đa 100 được ạ nhưng bạn
Nhập đây là 200 thì khi bấm vào đây nó
sẽ cảnh báo cho các bạn này chẳng hạn
đấy cũng đã xem một vài cái nho nhỏ nữa
đúng không ạ
Và Cái quan trọng là mình hoàn toàn thì
Điền trước được cho những cái này
từ điển thuốc cho nó là sửa mình điện
sẵn cho nó tên là Long này chẳng ạ thì
khi mới vào trang lập tức là nó sẽ hiển
thị ra cái này đứng yên định hoàn toàn
thể họ xóa đi nhé Đúng không ạ Vâng thể
xóa đi thì chị không sao ngờ như mình đã
nói khi mình bấm vào reset thấy vì bấm
vào reset nó sẽ khôi phục lại không phải
xóa nạn bộ nhưng cái đã điên những cài
đặt ích mà nó sẽ khôi phục lại phom như
ban đầu thì ra là thành ra là cậu các
bạn sẽ sẽ thấy cái cái cái reset này nó
không bản chất không phải là clear nó
phải Xóa à
khi bật van thậm chí là mấy ông thấy có
một vài trang nó sẽ ra kiểu đểu
read-only mà chẳng hạn chuyện cho xem
thôi các bạn sẽ thấy ở đây Nó gần như
chị cho cho Bôi copy thôi chữ nó không
trong sửa để lại nhập không sửa được
không ạ
Ừ cái hàng read-only này sẽ có nhiều Ông
nhầm sang với cả disable nữa đi xe bồ
thì các bạn phải nói rõ ràng nó nhảy
sang hạn mugi nó cũng cho copy cũng
không cho sửa có nhiều bạn bị nhầm cái
disable glycerine Nhưng cái video Ly nó
sẽ khác rồi đi với bồ ở một điểm duy
nhất đó là thằng read-only
phreeoni nó sẽ vẫn sẽ đẩy cái thông tin
trong cái input này 7 theo cùng cái
phone khi mà các bạn sắp ít con Hằng đi
xây bồ là có nhà không đầy đi cùng luôn
cái vụ không cho dùng copy thì thực ra
có nhiều cách một là các bạn dùng htpl
để các bạn
thế hiển thị ra một cái đít một cái nói
chuyện một cái gì rất to rồi các bạn bè
Lên đè lên cái cả trang này thì giờ các
bạn Click vào cái đấy Tuy ở cái đấy Bí
Ẩn Nó kiểu để trong suốt đấy Kiểu kiểu
nó nó nó làm cho kiểu các bạn không like
trực tiếp được vào chữ thành ra là kịp
sẽ không không copy được các bạn Thể Xóa
đi hòa nhiều cách nữa Giống nhờ có phải
ông dùng ra Switch để mà nhăn cá Ông bấm
can.co ạ Nhưng thực tế là có nhiều cách
để lách điều đấy
mình có mình từng tài cái tiện ích và
tiện ích các bạn thực là kiểu gì kiểu
các bạn cũng sẽ có có tiện ích kiểu em
dabo copy học simple copy để phán cái
điều đấy à
anh nói chung là như mình ở từng nói đó
là một khi nó anh hiển thị trên nó đã
được loa về trên máy của bạn rồi thì có
rất nhiều cách để các bạn Thể cậu xem
được nó
các bạn chỉ cần ngò thôi
Ừ cái inbox hay này nọ access Đúng không
các bạn đang thắc mắc sắp xếp này này
sắp xếp này giống như vừa nãy mình nói
là có thể là kiểu access chị jpg với
thằng ạ thì khi bấm vào đây nó sẽ chị
cho chọn jpg đó nhà ở đây vẫn đang cho
chọn tất cả mình nhớ không lầm là sao
cái này thì vậy không ngờ cách gõ lắm
Ừ Nếu mình không nhớ ở đâu cái mình sao
Google thôi mình cha suốt mà
nhớ mấy cái này làm gì Một Vì nó có rất
nhiều cái thẻ
rất nhiều cái vậy nhỉ
ở đuôi đuôi
ở đó
em copy về là sóng à
đi
soi bây giờ nó chỉ cho phép chọn tất cả
ảnh đúng không Tự nhiên nó vẫn có thể
các bạn vẫn thấy nổi nó sao ô file nhưng
mặc định lúc đầu nó sẽ luôn Hiển thị tất
cả đúng không ạ
Ừ
đúng rồi tôi có giấu giếm thì mấy ông
tôi không biết gì không Tôi không biết
thì thôi cha mà Mấy ông không không cần
nhớ mấy cái này làm gì cả nhớ từ khóa
tra Google Được rồi à
em làm nào để hiện thị được cái phone
ngày tháng năm sinh nhá thì các bạn tạo
ra ba cái C đi ba hãy save option à
Ừ đúng rồi
ê ê
Vì
sao rồi Tiếp theo là mình còn những cái
gì nhỉ Mình còn và lù cho nó cho 10 này
ờ
chị đã sử Mình muốn chọn trước một cái
mình một tích trước một cái là sửa lớp
được hình ảnh nhớ mình muốn tích trước
cho nó là quản chị ạ thì bị sẽ có là
selected như này để chọn trước một cái
đúng không ạ Và cũng như là để cho đương
nhiên là ông con để sẽ lách thực một
phát hai hai cái cùng lúc Nếu Cho xin
hộp đấy Ông phải để cái này món tia bồ
không ạ bây giờ sự tôi sự sống thử nhé
Nó sẽ luôn nhảy xuống đến năm cuối nếu
mà ông cho thành Monte bồ thì nó sẽ là
khái niệm khác mà Thì bồ là chọn là kiểu
chọn được nhiều ấy sẽ kiểu khác nhớ
thường là tôi thấy rất ít ông trang web
và ứng dụng sẽ cách unti bộ em
có kiểu xe lách muốn tìm bổ nhưng mà ý
thôi Ở không dùng cái giao diện kiểu như
thế
Ừ đúng rồi Ông kia đang hỏi câu mà rất
nhiều sinh viên tôi từng họp nó Cậu biết
em có tận 100 năm ở đây xong rồi có 31
ngày xong rồi 12 tháng thì em phải tạo
màn đấy Cái sẽ lấy góc chân là anh tuy
nhiên là các bạn thấy cái điều rất là
thủ công nó ngon thế việc là sử em chọn
vào tháng 2 ấy muốn cái ngày nó nó ngày
28 rồi trở lại không có ngày 31 sau đó
thì Thượng chưa thằng hai của cái năm
nhuận để sẽ 29 ngày rồi có gì Vân vân
thì cái này mình sẽ không thể dùng bằng
HTML để bàn để mà hiển thị ra Minh thủ
công ngồi gõ như thế được đóng ngoặc
mình sẽ phải làm từ mình sẽ phải can
thiệp bằng ngôn ngữ lập trình Vì sao
mình sẽ dạy các bạn ra quyết để mua các
bạn có thể in ra được cái select option
tương ứng với cậu từ năm
1900 thường người ta thường lại làm thế
1900 đến năm hiện tại ạ Bởi vì nếu mà sự
mà ông Thế Hiển thị ở đây là năm 2021 mà
Ngon thì sang năm mới thì ông lại phải
vào đây Ông ngồi sữa cốt Thành năm 2022
không phải làm nông dân mới được công
đoạn II
Ừ đấy thì mình sẽ phải cắm thiệp bằng
ngôn ngữ lập trình để làm gì đấy
Ừ cái vụ làm ẩn hiện mật khẩu này nó là
dùng gia súc tích về làm ông ạ
Ừ nếu mà ý ông ở kiểu có một cái nút bấm
ở đây để hiển thị ra mật khẩu các bạn
vui nhập thì nó sẽ là can thiệp bằng ra
switch
a Tiếp theo là cái vừa rồi tôi có nói là
cái valeu có thể hoàn toàn thể tự động
viên Trước một cái gì đó nhưng mà không
phải cái thẻ nào áp dụng và lu để điền
trước và sự giới tính ở Úc lại phá lưu ở
đây là Nam để nó điên trước được mà đây
sẽ phải là chiếc cật như này để mà điện
trước một cái gì đó và như mình có nói
đó là riêng input radio thì nó sẽ chỉ
chọn 1 nếu mà ông là sự cả hai cái khung
nó chết cực thì bạn chất nó sẽ chỉ Chọn
một thôi nó sẽ theo tháng cuối và tương
tự thế với những chiếc bóp thì các bạn
sẽ dùng truy cập được là sự nhớ ai đâu
mà đi
em gửi tiếp theo nữa là với ảnh đại diện
thì các bạn sẽ không dùng Zalo được ông
không dùng birudo trong này thì bọn nó
sẽ không chọn cho ông sẵn một cái ảnh
nào đó đâu rồi từng thử rồi đấy tiếp
theo nữa là mô tả bản thân họ là cái
kiểu te quiero rồi thì các bạn lại không
dùng Peru được các bạn sẽ phải điền các
bạn điện thẳng ở trong này bạn em tơ
trong máy các thứ để nó xuống dòng
enter thẳng trong ngày như thế này
thì nó sẽ xuống dòng này
thì nó sẽ lấy đúng toàn bộ những cái dấu
khoảng trống ở trong này để nó cách ra
như này cho các bạn luôn nên là đấy do
mà mình phải viết liền như thế thì sẽ
biết liền trong ngày như thế này
A và cái cái câu này thì ra còn thêm một
vài cái thì thay đổi size nó nữa nhưng
mà cái đấy cho cả các bạn muốn tìm hiểu
sâu hơn về giao diện thì các bạn tự mò
nhé Không ạ đi
ờ ờ
thì mình sẽ chỉ nói thêm về hai cái nút
này thôi cũng còn lại có bạn hỏi và sự
khác nhau với cái nút này Biến nút này
mày nút mặc định của của cái form nó sẽ
kiểu các bạn muốn thể cho nó vô lu Alo ở
trong trường hợp này lại là để nó hiển
thị ra như thế nào là sự đây là đăng ký
em ạ
và đây sẽ nút nhập lại ạ
Nhưng mà thực tế Mình đang đi làm thì
thấy cái này nó rất là khó chịu và thực
ra là nó không tiện bởi vì đôi khi các
bạn chèn thêm cả mấy cái kiểu biểu tượng
ngồi sau này thì rất khó không tiện
thành ra là thường là các bạn bây giờ
thường anh dùng nó là kéo cái nút như
thế này đăng ký em ạ Ừ nếu mà các bạn để
bắt Tần mà không Điền một cái gì cho nó
cả chúng nó sẽ hiểu thay con sắm ít thay
nó sẽ bóng xem ít để ông ạ và đứng như
sẽ có thay đổi Xét luôn
nhập lại này nó sẽ là nút Các bạn thấy
em nút nó dùng hết cái nút vừa rồi thôi
nhưng mà kiểu nhà thì các bạn hoàn toàn
thể điền thêm rất nhiều cái trong này
nhìn nó cưng minh hơn kết hợp việc là có
cả nút đương nhiên có nút là nút Austin
như thế này nghĩa nốt Chánh Nghĩa gì cả
Đây là nút bấm cho vui Ở Lại
xe tải kéo nha à
hai nút này sẽ được nhìn nhập lại nè
à mà núi này bấm cái nó sẽ đẩy family đỡ
ngoan
Ừ Đấy mẹ nói qua toàn bộ tất cả các cơ
bản của form cơ bản thôi đương nhiên về
sau như mình đã nói đó cứ cản buổi sau
mình dậy thì nó sẽ kiến thức mà sẽ gần
như phải xóa cốc cũ đi để mạnh học lại
phải cái mới độ ngon
ở mấy cái các bạn đang hỏi có phải cái
mình chả đợi lời được Nếu như mình dậy
mình trả lời được rồi nho mình nghĩ là
về sau mình sẽ trả lời các bạn chưa mình
không bỏ qua là nhé Có phải cái thì nó
sẽ không nên trả lời được ngay tại bây
giờ xảy ra mình sẽ không trả lời không
thể trả lời Giờ thì các bạn còn tì thứ
để họp mà có rất nhiều cái phải đến cảnh
mấy mấy bữa nữa mới học bên mình trả lời
hết thì các bạn cũng không hiểu vào buổi
nữa các bạn cũng không nhớ câu hỏi đấy
đã
cái khung này đúng không cái khuôn này
như tôi lúc đầu nói cho À không để ý nó
chính là thấy bồ đấy Cái này bản chất
khung này thấy bổ chứ for nó không phải
là tạo ra cái khung này đâu không Này Đã
Thay bồ xong rồi poder bằng 1
Ừ Ông học lại bài thơ bồ đi nó sẽ bao
gồm 2 cột
ý
nghĩa là bài này sẽ kết hợp cả thay bồn
Tí và kết hợp với phom ngoài và trong
trường hợp đấy thì for phải ôm cả thể
thấy bồ nhé hoặc thời cà phê Bồ ôm cả
cái form cũng được nhưng mà chuẩn người
ta thường phải làm sẽ ra form ôm thấy bồ
à à
Ừ
nếu mà đã từng có sinh viên mình quên
điều đấy quên đóng Hải phongnguyễn Chí
quên cả thẻ con thì khi mà các bạn tạo
ấn nút để bấm thì thôi ca nút này sẽ
không bấm được là sự bị xóa luôn thấy
con đây này quan thể bấm nó chạy nghĩa
gì cả
nên các bạn bắt buộc phải có thể Phone
Mà nó hiểu được là cái nút này Bấm để
cho hoạt động được cái phone này được
quá à
E73 toàn bộ kiến thức của ngày hôm nay
mình mình sẽ ghép
em nhảy sang cái chia sẻ
và trả lời câu hỏi đầu video đúng
ờ ờ
thì mình sẽ cách chia sẻ cái này trước
đã rồi trả lời đúng
anh chia sẻ cái này nó khái niệm là
anh làm sao để thiết kế một cái for tốt
hơn này
Ừ mình vừa học iPhone sao nước ngoài thì
đường sẽ giúp luôn
đầu tiên à quy tắc này mình thấy chưa ra
đến bây giờ nằm vẫn ở ổn cho dù rất
nhiều trang web không theo cái quy tắc
về giao diện này lắm nhưng cái này tùy
người ta mà nó không ạ
ờ ờ
ở đầu tiên là form nên nằm trên cùng một
dòng bởi vì sao Bởi vì a mắt ngủ của
mình mình nên đọc lướt là từ trên xuống
dưới đây nhiên cũng đọc từ trái sang
phải nữa nếu mà các bạn sự rất khó chịu
khi mà các bạn đọc một cái phone là từ
trái sang phải sao lại xong rồi lại phải
quay sang bên trái rồi xuống dưới rồi
trái sang phải rồi quay sang bên trái cơ
thể dễ thay vì thế các bạn đọc liền tù
tì từ trên xuống dưới thì mắt các bạn nó
sẽ trải nghiệm tốt hơn để gặp lướt
Cái này là lời khuyên của mếu mày thôi
Nhưng mà anh nhớ mình thấy là không phải
ở đâu áp dụng em mình cứ đang chia sẻ
các bạn với con điểm này á đù ngon ạ
a Tiếp theo là cái lấy bội lần này có
bạn để cặp label đây bộ phận chất nó lại
kiểu cách tiêu đề của cái đi lần này
thôi không ạ thì nó ra Kiểu Ngạn nhãn
dịch ra nhãn hiệu thế thì nó nên nằm sát
với cái cái bút thay vì cậu nằm kiểu
Chị sẵn à Kiểu song song kiểu như thế
này nó lên nằm trên người cốt là nằm sát
với cái nút thực tế là cái này về giao
về giao diện theo kiểu dùng CS để làm
chứ không không dùng mình htl thì mình
không thể làm cho mình cái này là sát
được nhau như thế này nhưng không làm
thì không thể làm thế được
ở cái đoạn này thì cũng đề cập mình vừa
đề cập vụ là cái label nên nằm sát vào
game bút này bởi Tránh trường hợp mà
label kiu ngoài mình sẽ đôi khi còn Nhầm
cái lấy bồ này của cái bút trên cho vay
của anh phút này nặng tại nó sẽ rất là
loạn tiếp theo là không nên viết hoa
toàn bộ về cái Lê bồ tôi từng gặp với
trang web được ngại vì nó hết cái tiêu
đề chẳng hiểu là em tí nhưng để nhấn
mạnh kiểu thế Chí Phèo như mình vừa nãy
còn nói đó là
Ừ cái sẽ có một vài trường hợp các bạn
không nên kiểu cáp dụng sẽ lấy cặp chân
rất nhiều trong trường hợp mà khi mà nó
chỉ có dưới 5 cái lựa chọn thì các bạn
nên hiển thị là một là radio Vaio là
ngon checkbox gì đấy Rio Nếu mà trường
hợp các bạn chỉ muốn thích 1 đóng ngoặc
thì các bạn ấy nhỉ thị hết ra tất cả các
khác lựa chọn đầy hay vì phải mất hai
cái click và Cái quan trọng là người
dùng lúc đầu người dùng không biết là nó
có những lựa chọn nào này Dũng sẽ không
hiểu thay vì cứ hiển thị ra hết lựa chọn
ở đây trải nghiệm người dùng sự tốt tốt
hơn a
tiếp theo là không nên có tôi lại thấy
có vài trang web về nhà Ôi không để một
tí Lê bù nào cả ông ấy ông ấy ghi mỗi
play order gợi ý cho người dùng cần phải
điền cái gì ạ sau đó thì thành ra là giả
sự ông mà nhìn thấy cái phone của dạng
là không bốn cái như thế này
a44 cái như này đúng không
ông ông chồng biết được cái thứ hai cái
thứ ba là phải điền cái gì ông ấy phải
xóa hết pin thì không hiển thị ra cái
gợi ý của nó ra sẽ nghiệm người dùng rất
tệ vụ này
ở đây như có vài xanh mà nó hiển thị ra
cả cái biểu tượng ở đây thì tượng cái
tượng người dùng này biểu tượng Mật khẩu
này với tượng email này Thế còn tạm chấp
nhận được
Ừ chứ cổ trang mà kiểu không có một tí
thông tin gì như thế này ông không nhớ
cái lấy bộ thứ ba thứ hai nó phải điềm
gì đâu không ạ
Ê bà như và nãy mình có đề cập là để mắt
mình trải nghiệm tốt đấy mình không nên
để xếp theo hàng ngang mày nhìn xếp theo
hàng dọc không ạ xếp theo hàng dọc để
mình đập nước là tốt lại easy to scan
nghệ đúng kiểu đọc lướt lập quét Ừ đấy
tiếp theo nữa đó là
Cho
ké nút nó lên tường minh một tí nốt là
nó nên là nút kia hẳn đã đăng ký này
đăng nhập này xong rồi Huy này thay vì
sắp ít rõ ràng vừa rồi Các bạn thấy lạ
input Nếu mà ghi tay mình sắp ít thì
mình sẽ sẽ ghi hẳn chữ xăm ít ông
Internet Explorer nó còn đi hẳn là gì
nhỉ ạ Sắp mcquarrie chẳng hiểu sắp
mccreery là cái gì cả đúng không
Thế Thành ra là kiểu người dùng sẽ khó
hiểu cái nút cái khái niệm cái nút đấy
gọi là nút kho tụi chân nút hành động
thì nút đấy phải luôn cậu
không những là cậu khác biệt với màu
nhấn mạnh cũng như là cậu em yêu cầu
dạng và cậu nó lên kiểu ghi rõ thằng
Minh hơn không ạ
Ừ cái này tiếp theo là nên hiển thị lỗi
ở ngay trên cùng dòng đấy cũng như là
kiểu hiển thị rõ ra lỗi là gì thay vì
hiển thị em một lỗi sinh chung
tôi
chửi thẳng luôn đó là thẳng Vietcombank
Em định hình thế Ford đều thậm chí ăn nó
tôi gần đây nhất tôi vào đền cái phom
của nó Ờ
tôi phải vào sửa hẳn xe HTML nó cả dùng
ra suis chạy nền để mà nhập được Vào cái
phòng của nó iPhone nó còn báo cái lỗi
gì đó
em chẳng hiểu sao
nó cho cha Tra cứu đơn đúng không đáng
sợ đó thì nó còn không không Cái input
nó cái cái bút thần nút đấy mà không cho
bấm luôn nó để đi xe bồn ông Ấn nút mà
rõ là mình vừa Điền xong vậy đầy đủ
thông tin từ trên xuống dưới cay nên tôi
vào rừng xanh ra Speed về máy sắp ít
được cái to mới đi không bị for này
không thể đẩy đi được nếu mà ông không
thấy nói chung hoạt cả nó là cái gì đó
kiểu ông ông biết về tí web với hoàn nó
cho biết về bên lập trình học hoàn toàn
thì vào sửa khác tên lò lẫn cả
Nói chung là dùng Sơn La Suite để mã cậu
nó không nhăn nông làm mấy cái đấy được
làm như thế
a cho tôi vẫn cay vụ đấy
à à
a tiếp theo là không nên kiểu người dùng
đang điểm đến đâu nó cũng hiển thị đoàn
lỗi này tôi từng gặp cũng có trang web
kiểu như này cơ hội người dùng chưa điền
song ngữ hiển thị lỗi người dùng cứ
tưởng người dùng nó nhập sai hàng qua
người dùng chơi điện xong hết thôi Kiểu
như này thông báo email không hợp lệ chợ
đi ăn xong thì cứ thong báo thôi người
dùng sẽ rất khó chịu và người dùng sẽ
phải ngồi kiểm tra lại xem mình đã nhập
gì đó sai ý
a tiếp theo là mình không nên ẩn đi mấy
cái gợi ý này mình lên hiển thị ra toàn
bộ những cái thông tin kiểu phải điền ở
đây này tôi từng thấy có một chàng nó để
cái gợi ý của cái điên ý ở cuối cha luôn
ạ và phải sau luôn cả cái á đi nghỉ Điều
khoản sử dụng và rõ ràng thực sự thực sự
là chẳng ông gần như đây phải 90 90 có
khi còn nhịn cái con nít chưa Mức phần
trăm mấy ông còn có bấm xem để đủ với
Điều khoản sử dụng Bệnh viện nó có cái
yêu cầu để mà điền cái in cũ tế nó còn
dưới luôn cả cái Điều khoản sử dụng cụ
bấm là đường Linh ấy mở ra việc là ông
phải điềm gì rồi đây này sanh ra cậu rất
là rất ức chế họ đánh đố người dùng các
ông Làm lập trình ấy
Ừ cái tự cái châm ngôn để mà Mấy ông
Lương cao ấy đó là người dùng cả mất não
người dùng
người dùng kiểu không có não mà vẫn dùng
được Cái trang web của ông vẫn dùng được
cái phần mềm ông ấy thì lương ông càng
cao đây là đấy thôi ông mà làm cho người
dùng khó dùng người dùng phải động não
suy nghĩ nát óc mới xuống được Cái trang
web của ông ấy thì lương không ngờ cao
rồi hiểu không
kể từ khi sang phép của ông lần duy nhất
và hiệu gì thế cũng sẽ có thằng tạo ra
trang web xịn hơn cạnh tranh
ở đây giống như vừa nãy nói đó là mình
nên cậu nằm nổi bật cái nút ko phát
triển hơn nhẹ nút kẽm chúng chung như em
bởi vì nhiều người rồi Tao thích bên
phải hơn tao không biết bên trái Nếu mà
mày để nút này tao bấm hai bên phải thì
sao chúng ạ ạ
chứ không phải khách hàng là thượng đế
khách hàng là người đưa tiền không mà
không phải chiều nói chứ chắc chắn rồi
nó đưa tiền đó ông mà ông mà nó còn phải
chìa ông đã thì Rốt cuộc ông khi vợ ông
cao hơn
từ lúc này Ông phải một đẳng cấp giấy đó
được phải giống như kiểu thằng Facebook
với đa dạng thế về thằng Facebook nó cứ
thay đổi cái gì đó là người dùng phải
theo nói có thể bởi người dùng Nó bị
nghiện đó rồi dùng bị Phụ thuộc nó quá
rồi anh cứ thế mà hiện tại chưa có thằng
nào cạnh tranh với nó anh ra kiểu ông
Đành phải thế Nhưng bây giờ sự thời
trang web của ông là không được như thế
đầy Hoàn cạnh tranh rồi Ông còn cố làm
khó mình dùng nữa thì thôi cậu nhỉ à
Ừ đấy thì giống như phải nãy mình có nói
đó là một cô input ra sự ở trong trường
hợp này Ngậm mã bưu điện thì nó sai nó
nên bé lại nào sai là không nên to quá
Này người dùng cứ tưởng phải nhập dài
lắm đúng không ạ
A và không nên để rất nhiều cái sao như
này thực là mình thấy bây giờ đến cả
Google form thường ai lại rất nhiều sao
nhé nhưng mà thằng goforth mình nó làm
thì cậu nó đại trà ở nó không quan tâm
giao diện lắm nhe chuẩn là là các bạn
không cần phải đàng sao tất cả một cái
mà các bạn có thể đi kiểu ngay và cái
cuối này thì bạn thể Việt tùy tùy chọn
là tuyệt trình Arsenal là kiểu có thể
Điền 20 Điền có thể để chống nóng ạ sẽ
trải nghiệm người dùng sẽ tốt hơn thay
vì một cái for các bạn 20 cái ô cần phải
nhập ông để sao hơn Tận 20 cái vì dùng
thấy ra cái sao thấy xa nghĩa gì cả cái
ô nặn cũng phải nhập chịu thuế
và cuối cùng tổng kết Nó là cái này các
bạn thấy nó sẽ khác biệt luôn này Cái
bên phải nó là không nhóm theo một cái
cái thứ tự gì cả con cái bên trái thì ah
nhóm theo dõi thông tin cá nhân này
thông tin tài khoản này so Thông tin
Liên đã trải nghiệm người dùng sẽ tốt
hơn rất nhiều
thế này về trải nghiệm người dùng đó mà
tôi nãy giờ tôi đang đề cập là thay đổi
giao diện Ui để ux nó ngoác và thêm một
cái nữa đi Mình nhắc lên cái cuối Tự
nhiên nhớ đến một cái nữa cũng rất là
hay nó vì cái cũng nằm trên Copa này nó
là cái á
gì khác à
Ừ hình như cái này thì phải
Anh nhớ một cái nào đó
à à
Sau
đó các bạn thấy đều
vì thế bị cho xem toàn màn hình cho
à à
anh đó gọi điện tên thông tin này
trải nghiệm người dùng nó kiểu bị kích
thích khi mà gõ trên mấy cái này đúng
không Nhưng đó
đẹp và xịn đúng không
Ừ nếu em Thực ra cái này không ở cái xịn
nhất em cái xịn nhất mình từng gặp nó
đẹp cực
khi cha đâu nhỉ
Tik Tok li ti rồi mẹ
cô gái xinh nhất mình từng lưu lại nhờ
mình cháu đến không biết đến bao giờ nữa
Ừ hình như là cái này
Ừ đúng rồi đúng rồi và cái này
Anh
điên à
Ừ Cái quan trọng nhất là cái này Tôi
thích cái này nhất này Nó thể tự ông
nhập cái nhưng mà đơn Nó có sẵn danh
sách rồi mà Hình như là của của nước
ngoài rồi phải đó là ông nhập cái mã của
cái ngân hàng của cái gì nhỉ à
xin visa nói gì Nói chung là đại khái nó
là cái hãng gì đó Chắc thế Không không
nhớ tên cho nó thì nó sẽ đổi màu để tuân
theo cái hạn này luôn và tên của hãng
luôn kiểu như này
Ừ nó visa Nếu mà ông 400 Đang đâu nó sẽ
hiểu đi ra này Đấy số này đang đầu là sẽ
hiểu là của hãng này Bấm ở đây để hiển
thị ra cái như thế này nhá lật lật lật
chậm xinh vãi
Ừ cái này nó sẽ tự cho Android tao rồi
nha thèm lại không không đúng đâu
Ông đừng hi vọng cái gì cả Em hãy Sino
Ừ nó nó mới chỉ có một vài cái ngân hàng
nhất định thôi Nhưng mà ông thấy trẻ
nghiện người hùng người dùng rất thích
cậu Tao muốn lên đấy tao điểm thẻ Thư
Tao không mua xe khác kiểu như thế nào ạ
Ừ cái này rõ ràng cốt chia sẻ rồi đấy
ông ấy Ông thấy tham khảo người không có
Quốc về nó htl tự nhiên có tính CS rất
là nổi giao diện điều này phải sẽ đổ ra
Speed rồi ông ạ
Ừ nhưng mà cái này về sau các bạn học
xong thì ta là nó không hẳn đến nỗi mức
độ khó lắm đâu cái đoạn này lập dễ hiểu
lắm Dạo này được mỗi cái dài vì nó cần
directly cậu nó tạo ra Đun thẻ dưỡng tạo
kiểu hiển thị màu thôi nên mới cần giá
Switch còn không chỉ cần hlcs ôm về là
có xong hết rồi anh
3G Speed đoạn này tốt để Mà kiểu cũng là
để mà tự động Điền khi mà á ông gõ như
thế này thì nó sẽ tự động điền vào đây
nữa Ngoan Bởi vì lúc đầu của htl của nó
làm gì có cái chữ Đức Nguyễn Nam Long
Đâu đúng ạ
desk with bản thân nó là khi họ thay đổi
bị gì đó chỉ cái nó có thể làm được
những cái gì đó dáng kiểu như thế nó
trong các động
À
thế à Xong rồi Thế còn như là các bạn
hôm nay vẫn biết được for nữa Ngoan Rồi
các thứ các bạn cũng thấy kiểu cái toàn
bộ HTML nó sẽ gồm những cái gì rồi đúng
không ạ
à à
cô không mấy cái ngân hàng và nhà nước
là nó sẽ không ôm bất kỳ cái giao diện
thì ra chuẩn mày cái bên nhà nước lại
không dám ôm nó diện ở bên nào nó về đâu
mà họ sẽ phải tự cốt họ tự cố thì cứ khi
chưa chán à
ừ ừ
Ừ rồi mình vì phép chia sẻ nốt cái này
trước khi kết thúc của ông anh nhé em
ờ ờ có bạn này hỏi vì tóm gọn lại theo ý
hiểu của mình đó là
có nhiều người bán mì cái điệu về một
năm lại vĩnh viễn này an gì đó
Cái kia họ cả bản quyền gì đó đúng mà
Thì tại sao mà cái kia đúng hết một năm
thì nó không chạy được nữa hay à hay là
phải có key mới chạy được rồi anh hoặc
khái niệm crack Nó là cái gì mình ngoan
Vân nó ngon thì để mình giải thích về
cái vụ này
Đầu tiên thì có cơ chế thì cơ chế Đó là
lúc đầu khái niệm phải biết là offline
và online đã có những cái phần mềm mà
các bạn cần phải dùng online giống như
là cậu các bạn đăng ký YouTube premium
này hay là kiểu spotify premium này
chẳng hạn thứ là sao kẽ là các bạn phải
kết nối mạ thì các bạn mới dùng được
Ừ cái cây nhôm có để các bạn không phải
dính quảng cáo nữa chẳng hạn đúng không
Đấy mình cái ví dụ đơn giản thôi thì cái
đấy hoàn toàn ở các bạn không thể lắc
được cái bản quyền của nó bởi vì bạn
luôn phải gửi lên cho nó 1 cái gọi là
cái cái chi đúng không một cái đoạn Mã
rồi đó và nó sẽ kiểm tra xem mà cái đấy
hợp lệ không để một ví dụ thôi nhưng ở
bây giờ đôi khi là chẳng cần người mãi
gì cả các bạn đăng ký đăng ký cho tài
khoản và các bạn đăng ký vào tài khoản
các bạn phải đứng yên đấy nó sẽ luôn
kiểm tra sang tài khoản các bạn đã còn
hiệu lực hay không các bạn trừ phí do
bạn hack được các khoản các bạn phải có
hiệu lực Thành Vĩnh Viễn thành hãng ho
gà không hạt ở vĩnh viễn Thường mấy ông
làm theo kiểu thời theo thời gian như
thế không khái niệm bao giờ vĩnh viễn
thì các bạn phải để nó ra hẳn trăm năm
1000 năm nữa không Giờ hết hạn đấy ạ ạ
ý thì cái đấy chỉ có thể hack thôi mặt
tiền thật Ừ nhưng mà còn nói là cái
trường hợp và crack thì nói thiên và cái
thường trường hợp và offline dùng được
offline dùng được Tức là sao Nghĩa là
nghĩa làm chỉ có bạn không cần kết nối
mạng đúng không có thể dùng được thì
nhưng mà đương nhiên là các bạn thấy à
Mấy cái đấy vẫn phải cậu lắm Còn không
thì nó vẫn sẽ như thế nào nghĩa là cứ
khi mày ông cái nồi mạnh thì nó lại bắn
về kiểm tra cho server của nó xem cái
tài khoản của ông hoặc key của ông
truyền lên nó nó dễ không hoặc thậm chí
là nó còn trước cái trò là nó có cái
đoạn mã kiểm tra sẵn ở trên máy cụ có
ông thì kiểm tra xem mà kẻ tri của ông
đang dùng có hợp lệ hay không nhưng
chính vì cái đoạn Mã để có sẵn ở trên
máy ông Thành ra ông hoàn toàn để tắt
được cái đoạn mai đi cũng như là ông ông
vừa nghe tôi nói là gửi lên cho cái sợ
gửi lên cái server vào nó để kiểm tra
xem
chị xem là cái à
em xem cái kia hợp lệ không đúng không
khi bóng kết nối mạng nó thế đấy là có
trường hợp với ông chỉ cần là chặn cái
server đấy không bao giờ gửi cái gì lên
cho nó thì nó sẽ không được kiểm tra
được
đương nhiên là nó sẽ không bị nhược điểm
nữa đó là nó không kiểm tra được cũng
như là nó nghĩa là ông sẽ không vào tải
được cái mới nhất phiên bản mới nhất của
cái phần mềm ấy
được Bởi vì nếu mà kiểu Ông Bật tính
năng tự động cập nhật thì đương nhiên là
nó sẽ phải kiểm tra đúng không bê tông
trạm nó bị kiểm tra cụ gì
đấy liên quan bị cái cơ khái niệm crack
và bản quyền offline có bạn vừa rồi cũng
hỏi rất là hai cái cái hack
mà tại sao có trường hợp liên quan đến
hack thì thì bản chất về cái vụ khách để
thì đột kích hay các thử là dẫn chứa
nhiều các bạn nói về hack game mà ạ thì
nếu mà nếu mà nhé nếu mà ông mà kết nối
một trăm phần trăm
cho đến một con server để ông chơi game
ấy
Ừ thì ông sẽ không vừa hack được trước
khi uống
anh không bờ tại tool về hack được trong
đại khái niệm trước khi ông kiểu ông
khách được cả cái số khối của nó theo
chào ông nói chung cho khách cả server
cả mà Bây giờ nhiều chỉ cần tải mới tung
gì đó Về hồi đấy Đột Kích chẳng hạn đúng
không Không hack được dễ dàng ông nào
cũng cậu pháp sư
cắm mặt xuống đất bắn chết người hay sót
các thứ thứ tư là mê định là mẹ đấy Kiểu
gì Tại sao lại dễ dàng như thế ta chỉ
đến đàn bởi vì à Các bạn thấy bây giờ
game mình không thể chăm chăm kết nối
trực tiếp thằng kia được mà thường hay
tải về quan trọng phải tải về
mà tại sao lại tải về bởi vì mạnh của
ông ấy ổn định cậu mùi chuyên game như
thế được rất nhiều ông cùng chim như thế
thì thằng servo nó chết là mạnh của ông
chết thành ra là cậu nó sẽ cho ông tải
về rất nhiều cái
thì nó sẽ lưu và trên chính máy của ông
mà thường là mấy cái răng đấy nó lạnh nó
hơi bị Nó kiểu nó có thể tính toán chưa
kĩ có rất nhiều thẳng người đấy nó tin
nhắn chữ kỹ
Ừ nó nó ví dụ giống như các bạn vừa chạy
vừa bình luận không đúng rồi ý mình đã
định nói đó có rất nhiều cái hoàn toàn ở
các bạn có thể trình ở trên máy mình và
chị mình mình thấy nó chính là cái trang
phục hoặc dẫn chứng cả bản đồ thế là
tiếng của game vì hoàn toàn mới cái đấy
tải về trên máy của ông Nếu ông ạ Ông
hoàn toàn thể chỉnh được và nó không ảnh
hưởng gì đến game cả thành ra là là
thằng thằng game Nó hoàn toàn cho phép
và không hẳn lại cho phép nhưng nó nó
phải cho tải đồng ý về để cho đỡ phải
nặng Xin lỗi ông lót game ông phải tải
hết đồng ý về chết thì nên là nó sẽ luôn
tại về cho ông rất nhiều cái về trang
phục này à à
nghe
tiếng âm thanh vân vân vân này nhưng mà
đã từng có vài thẳng như mình nhớ không
lầm cả đuôi kích thì phải nó là kẹo
cho ông tải về cả luôn cả về cái cách để
nó tính toán bắn chết một người kéo cờ
thế thành ra là cái tool hack kia bản
chất là nó chỉ được thay đổi thế cái
công thức để tính để thành ra là cao ốc
bắn bất kỳ vào đâu Nó vẫn chết người
biết khái niệm auto a mà ngon tự động
kiểu bắn Ban đầu cũng chung ấy đấy Kiểu
như thế ông kia thay đổi công thức 1
bóng bột các bạn nó luôn đúng rồi ạ hàng
ra 200 bắn vào đâu chết giờ hết hoặc à
Cái cậu nhìn trên bản đồ hoa chạy chạy
gì cho thành flash đúng không tiền như
thế cũng bản chất à Mấy cái game đấy
rằng Sao lại cho ông tải về cả mấy cái
Thuật toán tính toán của nó cứ bước đi
chạy 2000 Ừ thì được xin tường thứ mấy
ông Chỉnh hết mấy cái thông số lấy hàng
ra cậu đúng rất là ba đứng yên là mấy
thằng game đầy nó không cho ông trình
luôn gặp tiền của mấy ông nói mong đi
mua súng rồi về cái đấy đến với tài
khoản như còn những cái kia đi Nó lại để
ông tải về thành ông tải về được thì ông
thể sửa được thành ra là của ông sửa
hiểu ý của ông sông nhưng mà ngoan trọng
là ông vẫn đẩy lên cho nó mấy cái thông
số hợp lệ thành ra là vẫn 7 đi xong
thằng kia chết người bóng gọn
đúng ngồi riêng tiền những bọn nó không
mỗi cháu trình hơi buồn cười à
Ừ
Đấy bây rồi Mình đã nói qua hết về crack
và hack các thứ từ cái đấy không liên
quan để bên
lập trình web cho lắm Nếu mà mình giải
thích quay cho các bạn hiểu đây rồi các
kiến thức Qua của mình có bạn thôi Mình
cũng không từng hack nhưng không từng
crack mĩnh mình từng ra trước Nếu mình
không dừng hack và mình à
vì mình không biết grab chính xác này
không biết làm cái câu đấy
Ừ thì thành ra là kiểu mình không có thể
dành được làm như mày anh hacker để mà
nói xấu hơn được
là Thư cam bảo không nên làm đấy
Ừ để tôi mua bán kiện khá nhiều và xin
mail edu Lên mà lấy cái bàn Khuyến
à à tiếp theo là mình tranh thủ nói cứa
rách một tí thực cũng
ở chính giữa rồi nhà mình xin phép thêm
một vài phút để nói về cái vụ Jack về
bởi vì nhanh ngấm tiện lợi crack thì
nhiều ông cho cũng biết về vụ thằng
Windows cho ông crack mà thực ra Windows
Nó hoàn toàn thoải mái điều đấy Tại sao
nó không Không sợ đi có từng nhiều không
anh chơi Windows giáp với cậu đã bảo mật
kém như bê cả à á Nói thế rồi đấy thì
thì tại sao bởi vì bản thân thằng
Windows nó cố tỉnh cho ông mấy cái lỗ
Hồng thừa như thế thì mày ông hoàn toàn
dễ dùng win nhưng mà khi ông vào doanh
nghiệp thì ông kia ông đã quen dùng Win
đấy thằng rất là kiểu doanh nghiệp phải
cài Win và doanh nghiệp thì
Ừ cái Win thì chắc chắn nó không thể
crack được rồi nó phải mua bản quyền thế
là bọn nó thu tiền thì mình cái thằng
bạn mấy cái thằng kia chứ nó không
nó không thu tiền từ cá nhân và thực tế
là cá nhân nhiều cũng là chủ yếu học
sinh sinh viên nữa nó kệ thôi Nó kiểu
thế nên là cậu nhiều hút nhiều nơi bán
rồi thì kiểu xoăn bỏ ra kia em có cần
anh Jack hộ luôn chó không yêu thế nhân
viên nó có nói thẳng gì hết á
cô dạy khái như thế công sẽ biết được là
cậu Tại sao nó cho các thế đúng không
ở bên nước ngoài bé ngoài thì ông ông
crack thì đương nhiên là có tội rồi
Nhưng mà thường mà chẳng ông nào
áo kiểu hiếm lắm Có trường hợp Vợ ông ở
bị đập cửa để mà bạn bị bắt vì crack cả
nếu mà cũng nhiều mà doanh nghiệp với dự
án sẽ dính kể cả Việt Nam với nước ngoài
Nếu mà ở tượng chữa kìa có ông không
crack the gas công vẫn dung được một
cách thức đổi mới là không ạ ạ
khi nó cố tình cho như thế đấy để cho
bây lượng người dùng pin cao mà nó hoặc
à
anh nói chung là đại khái nãy thơ chia
sẻ rất nhiều rồi bây giờ nghỉ
tạm hôm nay kết thúc tại đây nhé
Ừ có gì những câu hỏi các bạn mình xin
phép Trả lời vào buổi sau nhé Chào các
bạn
ừ ừ